Everybody!
Okay, this is such a weird setup for my Switch.
I had to, I had to, I had to like Uber Eats like a travel adapter because my Switch is not like from NA.
So I had, like I, not, I guess I bought the Switch in Asia.
So I realized I didn't have any travel adapters so I had to like Uber Eats a travel adapter from fucking London Drugs.
So I could actually charge my Switch and I had to try and find my game capture, my game capture thing.
And then I had to find my, my, my fucking Switch controller because it's Mario Party and there's gonna be a lot of button mashing and everything.
And so, and then, and then okay so like what my setup is like right now is that so I don't really, I have another table.
But like I can't really use that other table.
So like what I have is that I got it.
I got my monitor and like I just placed it in front of all my other monitors.
Like it's, it's on my mouse pad.
Like I have to like, I have to like sit back a little bit because the, the monitor is literally like close to the edge of the table.
And then my phone is covering, you know, one sixth of the monitor.
So it's a really scuffed setup.
It's, it's such a fucking scuff.
Scuffed setup and everything.
And then I found out, I don't know, I didn't know but like I was trying to charge my Switch.
And I didn't realize one of the, the ports, the, the ports, it doesn't work.
It's a new, I don't know if you have to like turn it on or something.
But like one of the fucking ports was like for decoration.
It doesn't charge.
I thought it was because the adapter.
Okay.
I'm so fucking stupid.
I thought it was because the adapter.
I did have one extra adapter.
So like, I thought that like, oh, maybe my adapter was broken.
Like, I don't know.
It got burnt or some shit.
So then I was like, okay, I'm going to Uber Eats an adapter.
Sorry, the, what was it called?
You know, where you plug in appliances, like plug in for power.
Like that shit doesn't work.
So like it was not because my travel adapter.
Wasn't working is because there's no, like, there's no power on there.
Cause like, I was like, okay, let me just plug it in my, this other outlet and then see if it works.
And it, it works.
It, I was like, oh my God, I Uber Eats a travel adapter for no reason.
Like, sorry, I meant outlet.
Yeah.
It was a decorative outlet.
So I was like, I can't believe I fucking Uber Eats a travel adapter for no fucking reason.
So, so I wasted money there.
Anyway, it's fine.
It was like $20, 20 Canadian dollars.
So that's like one American dollars for you guys.
Um, well dog, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
I'm super excited.
You're streaming Mario Party on my birthday.
Let the chaos begin.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear dog.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
Anyway.
Um, let me double check if they're there.
Okay.
Are they there yet?
Or if I'm late?
I am technically not.
I mean, LM hasn't even added me on the switch.
I told him to add me, but he hasn't yet.
Unless like I didn't see the friend request.
No, he hasn't added me yet.
Like, what the fuck?
Okay.
I'm not late.
Cause like, I'm not, cause there's only two people there.
Um, so technically I'm not late.
Did I give him the wrong friend code?
Did I fuck up my friend code?
Let me double check.
Um, okay.
Okay.
Uh, oh, I should, I was about to read my friend code out loud.
Uh, no, I didn't.
Okay.
It's correct.
Nice.
All right.
I guess I'll hop on.
Hello?
Add me on switch.
Oh my God.
I haven't done that.
Wait.
Yes.
Can you?
Do you have like psych?
No.
Oh, okay.
Let me add you now.
Okay.
So by the way, if I sound really monotone today, I've been losing my voice a lot.
So I'm trying to like, Oh shit.
Wait.
Were you at Twitchcon?
No, no, no.
It's like, I've lost it like, like a little bit ago, but I've been never, I've been never, I haven't been letting it recover.
So if, oh yeah.
So you haven't taken a break.
You've just been like screaming at people.
I see.
Yeah.
At about an hour through, I'm probably going to mute for five minutes.
So just basically if I seem weird, there's nothing wrong.
I'm just having to do it.
Yeah.
You're just, yeah.
Your throat's just really fucked.
Yeah.
I get that.
Um, okay.
Let me, uh, let me argue.
Okay.
Wait, what's your, I won't do on stream, but like, what's your like thing?
Yeah.
I sent it to you on Twitter.
Oh, you did.
Yeah.
Oh no, not this year.
No, no.
I was just so busy this year.
Oh, I couldn't go.
Dang it.
Where did you go to the, um, did you go, which ones did you go to the Vegas one?
That's the Evo one, right?
Wait, there was a Twitch con at Vegas?
Yeah, dude.
It was like last year's one.
Oh no.
I didn't go there.
I was also very busy.
Oh, she doesn't like the cons.
She hates them.
Hates them.
I tell you.
No, that's not it.
No, I didn't go there.
I was actually really busy.
Oh, I was really, really busy.
My schedule was too packed.
Yeah, yeah.
No, I totally touch grass all the time.
Like I'm always outside going to places.
It's just, it was just on the wrong day, you know?
There was just something I had to do on that day.
Yeah.
I mean, you know what?
And I respect that.
I respect that.
Yeah.
I had a thing at that place one time, you know?
Oh, the thing with the thing with the thing and stuff.
Yeah.
With that thing.
I'm not a shut-in person.
Yeah.
I'm not a shut -in person or anything.
I actually socialize with people.
I swear to God, I'm not terminally online.
I swear to God.
And I believe you.
Yeah.
Dude, I'm going to get this code horribly wrong.
I already know I will.
Hang on.
Let me...
I double checked and I gave you the right code.
And you've been added.
Okay.
Nice.
There you go.
And I also have successfully not leaked your code as well.
Nice.
Thank God.
Pleased to know that I have not done that this time.
Okay.
There we go.
One, two, three.
Okay.
Let me try this one.
Let me do that.
Then, all I need is...
Wait.
Your name is not Ellum?
Your first and last name wasn't that?
Oh, my God.
That's so crazy.
My name is Doki.
You know, my...
So, Ellum, do you think that's my last name?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Your name is...
Is that public knowledge?
Do you know my last name?
Wait, why would I try to dox you?
Like, why?
No, because it's public knowledge.
Oh, it's public knowledge.
Okay, I was gonna be like, why wouldn't I know your last name?
I'm not gonna, like, sock you.
If I tell you it, you have to promise me you don't laugh.
Okay.
You ready?
Yeah.
It's Bingle.
Wait, is it actually?
What do you mean by, is it actually?
Why don't you just call yourself Bingle then?
That's so much better than that.
That's so much...
Oh my god, why don't you just call yourself Bingle?
Holy fu- Because the Bingle lineage ends with me, Dokie.
The Bingle lineage ends with you.
You can legally get your name changed.
You'd rather just fucking die alone than to change your name.
That's so...
Whoever I get married to, I'm not taking...
Like, they're not taking my name.
They're not taking your name.
The only...
The only way I would let them take my name is if their last name was Josh, so my name would be Josh Josh.
Josh.
Hey, what's up, guys?
Sykuno.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Did you know his last name was Bingle?
Oh, hey.
Oh my god.
Hey, Dokie.
Sykuno has known...
Has known about my last name.
He knows the tales of the Bingle.
Oh yeah, we used it as an insult.
No fucking way.
Like, if someone plays really bad, we'll be like, you Bingled it, bro.
Oh, so that's what it meant.
I was like wondering what you guys were saying.
Like, Bingle.
Yeah, I don't know.
I actually searched what the actual term of Bingle is.
It either means a car crash or an abnormally small penis, so both of which aren't great.
Is it?
I mean, yeah.
I agree with that.
I guess I wouldn't like either of those.
By the way, Syk, if I sound, like, more monotone today, I'm just trying not to raise my voice, because I lost it again yesterday.
Oh my god.
So I'm just, like, talking more, like, more, like, monotone.
So if I...
If there's nothing wrong, it's just...
No, that's okay.
That's okay.
One, two...
Do you have, like, the Discord link for Chilled?
Or I can make it just a separate call.
I can't believe it.
Wait, so, like, are you an only child?
Can you just give me one second?
Oh, okay.
Um...
No, I've got a brother.
Oh, okay.
So it doesn't end.
Unless he's also gonna...
No, the thing is, he actually likes our last name, which is the worst thing.
I'm like, look, you've gotta end it somewhere.
Does he know what it means?
I don't think so.
I think it's actually even, like, searched, um, what, like, my heritage is, like, in terms of what my, like, ancestors did.
And we were...
We were potato farmers.
You guys were potato...
I mean, like...
Are you part Irish?
Like, are you...
Are you...
Were you part of the potato famine?
Like...
Because of...
Oh, wait.
Do I need him on Discord?
Make it...
Make it group chat and I can...
Yeah.
Uh, yeah.
Let me...
I don't really want to group chat with this Andrew.
I don't really want to.
Somebody might...
I also need to go get my Switch from downstairs.
Oh, you're fine.
Oh, wait.
Don't need...
I need to add you on Discord.
I'll just make, like, a separate chat.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Something in my chat was, like, if he's got a bingle, it probably will end.
Bro!
That's his brother!
That's fucked!
Yeah.
It's...
It's cooked.
It's actually cooked.
It's bad.
I mean, if you're, like...
Linga...
Like, you're...
You're...
Your family has survived for generations with bingo.
Yeah.
It ends with me.
It just ends with me.
It's done.
You're gonna make sure your brother will find no one.
I'll be like, Oli, look.
That's my brother's name.
Wait.
What's your brother's name?
He's called Oli.
Oh, Oli?
Yeah.
Oli Bingle.
Dude, I mean, like, the Eopana, way better last name.
You should definitely take hers.
Like, definitely just take hers.
It's fine.
Just, like, you know, you don't need...
You don't need it.
It's fine.
Can't imagine Ella being a farmer, dude.
Neither can I.
Truly.
Oh, my God.
Not just a farmer, but a potato farmer.
He's part of the potato famine.
And I'm not proud of it.
Let me tell you that.
You're not proud?
I don't think the Irish are really proud of it either.
Oh, well, we're gonna switch calls.
We're just gonna do it in this other group, okay?
All right.
Yeah.
No problem.
Wait.
Is this not working?
I sent Sheldon an invite.
Okay.
I don't think he...
All right.
Well, maybe you should message him and be...
Oh, okay.
Hey.
It's like, Kudo said, chill the invite, so maybe we should just go back to...
Yeah, I don't know.
I sent him the invite like he should.
Oh.
Yeah.
So, should we just go back?
We can go back all the way.
We can just use this.
It doesn't matter to me, personally.
Like, it does...
Yeah.
Okay.
Hey, gamers.
Hey, what's up, man?
Yo.
Any TCG sim enthusiasts out there?
Oh.
I'm playing that tomorrow.
Yeah.
I just need Level 25, man.
Is it that addicting?
It's pretty funny.
It's pretty fun.
Yeah, I like it.
So is it like better than Supermarket Simulator or it's just like the same thing?
It's like ten times better.
Wait, how is it...
That game was busted.
How is it ten times better?
Like you can just fully automate it and then just be a goblin opening cards.
Wait, really?
Dude, you just get to rip packs the whole day while your employees are busting their asses?
You're just making money and you just...
Yeah, and then you don't have to pay real money for that too.
Wait, they actually have cards?
They have collectibles in it?
Check this out.
I got a Scarf Goris full art epic foil.
It's worth 2.7k.
Is anyone buying it or you just put it on display?
Dude, I ain't selling it.
I'm keeping it.
You're putting it in your collection?
How's your collection?
I got a Scarf Goris for 2.7k.
Wait, can you actually spend money for actual packs or is it like only in-game stuff?
No, it's only in-game.
You actually got to play the game, dude.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I think if this was multiplayer, it would have been even better with multiplayer.
I think in fifth grade, the kids would have loved me for this Scarf Goris, I tell you.
They would have thought I was the sickest dude around.
Back in the day, there was this like... I don't know what it was called.
It was this other card game that was on like the PlayStation 2.
And it would like bring the monsters to life like in Yu-Gi-Oh!
And I bought like every pack in this box.
I don't know what it was called.
That's not narrowing it down because they had a lot of them.
I thought it was like one of a kind.
Oh, shit.
I didn't even know that.
It was like Monster Rancher.
Well, Monster Rancher wasn't like a show.
Monster Rancher was like technically not cards.
Not cards, but they made a card game for it.
Oh.
They made a card game for that?
Really?
Yeah, I think they did.
I remember he was my guy.
Is it Eye of Judgment, LM?
That's what some people are saying.
Dude, that was it.
Yeah.
That was it.
That was the name of it.
Yeah.
That was it.
That was the name of it.
Judgment what?
Eye of Judgment, apparently.
Yeah, something like that.
And dude, I remember my mom bought us the entire box and just pissed off everyone in the card shop because just everyone was there for it and we just left for the entire thing.
Damn!
Okay.
Wow.
All right, Mr. Rich Man there.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what kind of mom would just buy the entire pack?
You know what I did when I was a kid?
I got fake Pokemon cards.
Yo, me too!
Yeah!
You know like when your grandparents or parents were like, here are those Pokemon cards that you wanted so much and they were just like stickers.
And they got it from the Chinese market and it was like fake ones.
Do you remember putting like the two quarters into the machine?
Yeah, the two quarters and those like the stickers in.
The two quarters you pushed and pulled out?
Yeah!
There's like ones in Pizza Hut and you can...
Those are such scams.
What in the name of American cards is this?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
So there's like, you can actually get fake cards, but they're not actually cards.
They're just really sparkly holographic stickers.
Yeah, they're like stickers.
Oh wait, I think I did have one of those.
Wait, wasn't that...
And I'm pretty sure they should have got sued into oblivion for this.
Wait, Doki actually knows exactly what I'm talking about.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
I had the...
I had a lot of them.
You also had the Yu-Gi-Oh!
versions too.
Yes!
Yeah, they had everything.
Yeah.
It was great.
Yeah, but you can tell how...
And then the Yu-Gi-Oh!
cards are like super cheap quality.
Like they're like off, like off-colored and everything.
I have to go get my Switch.
Give me like a...
Wait, you still have it?
I'm gonna go grab it.
I'll be back in like two minutes, guys.
I'm gonna go grab my Switch really quick.
You're fine.
I'm chilled and Doki.
I've invited you both.
Okay.
Great to see you again, Chilled.
I haven't seen you since we played Among Us five years ago.
Wow!
You know, I saw on TwitchCon, I saw as like the last day, you had a line that was just going way to the escalator and I'm like, oh, he's never gonna get out of there.
I had a six and a half hour meet and greet on the last day.
Oh my God!
That's awesome.
Six and a half hours?
It was the opposite of awesome, but like now I'm sick and weakened, but I'm glad to be home.
Glad to be home, you know?
That line was not shrinking because I walked by it twice in my life.
Wait, did they like not cap it at all?
Okay, but it was by the pretzel shop.
And when I finished, they gave me a free pretzel and drink.
Did they really?
Oh, that's kind.
Wait, is it just one pretzel?
Yeah, she ordered it.
What brand were they?
Was it Auntie Anne's?
It was Auntie Anne's, yeah.
I forgot.
Yeah, they were, they're the goats.
They gave me some free food.
Oh, that's sweet.
That's nice of them.
I'm gonna go grab my Switch.
I'll be right back.
Wait, what's the passcode?
Oh, LM Stefan.
I think it's gonna be...
Oh, wait, sorry, sorry.
I'll leave myself unmuted so you can entertain the chatters.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
Free entertainment.
Okay, do you have any other questions?
Do you play ATCG?
ATCG?
Yeah, do you play like a trading card game?
No, I don't really play it.
I like collected cards as younger, but I never like played the game, like the game itself.
I just thought they looked really cool.
I was just like, ooh.
And I get like a binder of all these cards because I was like, oh, the art's so pretty.
Also, LM, we need a passcode for Mario Party.
Oh, it's 1234, the uncrackable code, you could say.
Okay.
Oh, you just showed it.
Yeah.
I haven't showed it.
I sound like really monotone today.
I don't want to explain to everyone, but I'm recovering from a lost voice.
So, I might just sound like really uninterested, but I'm not doing it on purpose.
Thank you for letting me know that you're actually engaged and not uninterested in the conversation.
Thank you for actually being engaged.
I'm usually like very energetic.
I don't want him to be like, wow, this guy is a fucking asshole.
Thanks for inviting me, LM.
Appreciate it.
I really appreciate him.
Don't invite me again.
No, I figured you sound, yeah, it sounds like LM.
You sound like your throat might collapse any second.
I'm just, yeah, it's a whole thing.
I've like been drinking.
I've been steaming my voice prior to arriving here.
I've been had my head over a thing of boiling water, just inhaling steam.
Wait, do you have those?
There's like this throat medicine that you can take.
That's like syrup-ish.
I don't know if you've heard of it.
It's like a Chinese medicine that helps with the throat.
And singers take it a lot.
That would be wonderful.
I'm trying to remember the name.
Chad, do you guys know the name?
Chad?
Also, I might have accidentally leaked the room ID.
So like, we'll see.
No one plays this game.
We'll be fine.
Oh, it's a friend lobby.
So that's good.
Okay.
If we go through the trouble of stream sniping at Mario Party, they'd have to turn on their switch, load up the game, then probably do an update, then just arrive.
That's true.
Hey, honestly, at that point, they can just play.
Oh, yeah.
So Sakuna's out, Random's in.
I'm going to send you a link to this throat medicine.
It helps a lot.
Cause like singers use it too.
That would be awesome.
Is it called Peepagow?
Uh, yeah.
Peepagow.
I don't know how to pronounce it.
Yeah.
This, this one.
Okay.
This one's real.
It's really good.
Like you can literally like take it like before you head to bed and it like helps.
It's like you recover like almost instantly the next day.
Oh, wait, really?
Yeah.
It's really good.
I know a lot of like, uh, like VTubers also use it because like we also talk a lot and like sing and karaoke and concerts.
And stuff.
So it's like a super common thing that people take.
Oh, okay.
Awesome.
Wait.
So chilled.
You're like a Meyer potty professional, right?
Oh shit.
I mean, how long you've been a content creator chilled?
Oh God.
I can make you feel old right now.
I can.
So, uh, 2008.
Oh, all right.
2008.
Okay.
Chilled.
I can.
Little big planet.
I was still in high school back then.
Yeah.
2008.
Chilled.
I'll just say, I remember watching your content when I was very young.
Put me in a fucking ground.
Put me in a box.
All the way back when you were in The Creatures.
You watched The Creatures?
I watched The Creatures.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Okay.
He's an OG.
I used to watch The Creatures.
Me and Junk were the first ones kicked out of The Creatures.
Hey, you know what?
You're better off for it, right?
Yeah.
Look at you.
Look at you now.
You're right.
Now you're Chilled Chaos.
The legend.
The legend himself.
Now he's a multi-millionaire legend.
Exactly.
He's popular.
He's successful.
He's exposed him.
Dude, after all of my Yu-Gi-Oh card purchases, that number is going way down.
Dude.
No, you can sell those Yu-Gi-Oh cards.
Do you have a Starlight Rare IP Mascarena?
I heard that card's worth a lot.
No, but I did.
So, it's funny enough.
I did a...
They let me cast a World Championship Series a couple of weeks ago in Seattle.
And that was really fun.
And while I was there, I got a Starlight SP Little Knight.
So I was like, oh shit.
So that was really cool.
But no, Starlight SP Little Knight, unfortunately.
Not the IP Mascarena.
Now, do you have a PSA 10 Beaver Warrior?
No.
No, I don't.
But I have like a PSA...
Okay, so she's not graded.
But in my mind, she's like a 7.
A Dark Magician Girl.
First edition from Mirror's Force.
First edition?
Way back in 2005.
First edition.
Oh my god.
Wait, how much does it cost to get them graded?
I don't think too much.
Like maybe like $50 or $70.
Yeah, it's more to say that most people just like get worried because you need to like ship them off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a waste of money.
Because what if they say it's not that good?
And you gotta crack it out of the box.
And you're like, ah, see, it's new mint.
It's not really graded.
And then you gotta try and sell it.
Did I ever send you my collection of like OG Yu-Gi-Oh?
cards I have?
No, you never showed me them.
Dude, I have...
I need to send them to you.
I have like an entire pack, like box of them.
They're like pretty...
They're pretty...
Honestly, they're in good condition.
I don't know if I'd ever get them graded, but like all of the OG stuff.
But one time when I had a puppy, she kind of like got...
She got into the pack and then destroyed like half of them.
And it was like the most heartbreaking thing in my...
I was like, no, not anything but my Yu-Gi-Oh cards.
Anything but that.
Oh no.
It's a shame you had to put down the dog after that.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I was gonna say, you could sell the dog to make up for the damaged Yu-Gi-Oh cards.
But yeah, it's a little fucked.
That was more fucked than what I was gonna say.
Oh Jesus.
White dragon.
I had my tortoise...
Did you send the invite?
I'm on my...
Yeah, yeah.
I invite you, brethren.
I invited you.
Toki, my tortoise peed on some of my Yu-Gi-Oh cards.
Your tortoise peed...
How did...
How did your tortoise make it?
Yeah.
I was gonna say, how did it get there?
It's a fucking tortoise.
Is it like a house tortoise?
Is it like the same brain sometimes?
He's outside now.
But when he was smaller, you know, he was...
He could stay inside.
He was in a little enclosure.
Can I meet your tortoise and feed him a carrot?
You could.
You could feed him strawberries that looks like murder when they just explode.
Wait.
Tortoises eat strawberries?
I mean, they're vegetarians.
I love when turtles and tortoises eat because they slowly reach their neck out.
It's so fun.
Yeah.
You know?
Yes.
It's so fun to watch.
You could just watch him eat.
Wait.
Can you bring him to TwitchCon next time?
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
You should do like a TwitchCon meet and greet and see how many people want to meet your tortoise.
Dude, bring him to TwitchCon.
Charge 50 bucks for meet and greet.
Yeah.
And I would pay it to feed him some strawberries.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
It's not even a Twitch meet and greet.
It's a Twitch feed and greet.
Oh, my God.
Oh, dang.
That's the meta.
Yeah.
I would feed a tortoise his name.
Streamers bring their pets.
He's Tortolini.
Tortolini.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
It's like the Italian noodle.
I'm like, all right.
All right.
Tortolini it is.
Tortoise.
He's cool.
If you ever find yourself in Austin, you know, I'll let you know.
Wait.
How old is your tortoise or tortolini?
He's about four and a half.
Four and a half.
Wait.
How big is he?
Question mark.
Photo.
I want to see how big he is.
Yeah.
Let me get one.
He is probably 30 pounds now.
He's going to...
30 pounds.
The great part is he's going to outlive me.
This is a great part.
Pass him on to your kids.
Yeah.
He's got...
I'm...
He legitimately has...
He has to get willed to somebody.
Can you put me as, like, number 10 on the will if everyone above me doesn't want him?
Why number 10, Sarcuna?
Don't you want to be higher?
I'm not trying to fight for the number one spot.
He's probably got people there, but I figured he doesn't have a number 10 spot yet, you know?
I don't.
Number 10 is not filled.
I have...
Look, I got to be honest.
Okay.
If he's living to 100, I think we're all dead by this point, right?
I might live.
I would...
I would get downloaded into a brain.
That's true.
Like, the moon.
Robot.
We don't know where we're going to be in 100 years.
That's so true.
Gokey Bird can't die.
She's an animal character.
Yeah.
That's true.
I'm already on the internet.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Yeah.
All right, Chao, show you the picture of the tortoise, of Tortellini.
Tortellini.
Oh, my God, this is so...
I want to play more Animal Crossing.
I miss Animal Crossing.
It makes me think of Tortimer Island.
God, there was that, like, that little peaceful time and, like, that march.
It's like everyone was just playing Animal Crossing and Doom.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then they never updated the game.
That's my trigger word.
Yeah, I still play it once a week.
Wait, really?
Dude, invite me on the next one.
I'll play.
Would you like to join us?
The mods have gotten insane.
I mean, that's better.
The more confused and upset I get, the better content it is.
Wait, what game?
Among Us.
Oh, Among Us!
Yeah, do they have a new map now?
I play Pico Park, bro.
Oh, one or two?
Both.
Okay, now when you went with the group, did you take Elem in?
Oh.
Yeah, but that group never came back.
Like, me and Elem had a group, and that group ain't coming back, man.
Oh, we'll make it happen.
One day.
It's not happening, Elem.
That group's dead.
What's dead?
I'll tell you what, me, I would run it with Elem.
But like, some of them...
Do you play Pico Park?
Oh, the two-player Pico... Wait, you ended a session.
Why did you end a session?
I'm so sorry, I'm not...
Did you want to play Pico Park with this guy?
You know, that's part of the fun.
You're not wrong.
You know, I think multiple of them banned him from his chats, and also blocked him on Twitter from our Pico Park and other sessions.
Wait, how far did you guys get on Pico Park with Elem?
I feel like, honestly, we did pretty good.
Considering.
I don't remember, actually.
There's like...
I busted out the whiskey after half an hour.
There's like 14 worlds there.
I couldn't handle it.
Did you at least get to world three?
Did you at least...
We got like halfway, I think.
We honestly did pretty good.
Oh, that's pretty good.
Yeah, but how long?
How long did it take?
Oh, well...
How many sessions?
I feel like he's saying a lot of things, and I'm going to say low key, I don't remember if it's true or not.
We like...
It's hard to say.
Okay, I'm going to invite you all again.
I'm so sorry, I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, you guys, same password?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, same password, same password.
Wait, I'm waiting.
No, I have to ask though, are you guys all dongle dudes?
What the hell is a dongle dude?
Oh, okay, so do you guys, are you hardwired or are you Wi-Fi?
Oh, no, I have delay, and I will mod every single game.
Oh, okay.
It's so hard to play.
Oh, no, I'm not.
As long as you all have the delay, it's chilling, you know?
I'm also on Wi-Fi, so...
Yeah, I'm on Wi-Fi as well.
Alright, unplug...
If someone doesn't have the lag, then they're just going to dominate.
Chilled, you got to unplug the dongle right now.
You got to use the Wi-Fi.
I can go on Wi-Fi?
Like, let me tell you.
You got to go Wi-Fi.
It's so bad.
Not just in this game.
In other games, too.
Not going to say which one.
You have 10 plus years of Mario Party experience.
You got to unplug right now.
The delay.
Well, the real question is, do you guys play with the game instructions or no?
This is my third time playing Mario Party in my life.
Yeah.
I've never seen Doki Bird be bad at a game before.
Wait, Doki, is this your first time ever playing?
No, this is my third time.
This is my third time.
I never owned a GameCube growing up until the GameCube was about to die and had two games on it.
Wait, Doki, how old are you, if you say?
I don't know if you say or not.
He's 108.
Yeah, I'm 108.
I tell people I'm 26.
That's been my lore for seven years now.
I'm going to say I feel like my age didn't change much after 20.
I feel like that happens.
I feel mentally I'm the same as I've been since I was 25.
I feel like it's still the same.
I feel like ever since COVID, like everything just stopped at that time.
Nothing progressed after COVID.
We've just been stuck in our homes.
When are we getting Walmart for 24 hours again?
Why can't I go buy Yu-Gi-Oh cards at 3 o'clock in the morning?
You guys had Walmart for 24 hours during COVID?
Wait, chill.
Do you still play Yu-Gi-Oh now?
Because of COVID, we don't have that anymore.
Wait, wait.
You can teach me how to play again, man.
I've been trying.
I've been trying to learn.
Do you still only play the current day meta?
I used to only play the current day meta.
Because they were cool.
Oh, you're in luck then.
There's a new set coming out in December.
No, January.
And they're doing the Evil Heroes.
Some retrains of Evil Heroes.
Okay, but I'm like a cringe master duel only player.
Oh, yeah.
I know you play a lot of Yu-Gi-Oh online, Sykkuno.
I used to.
Oh, yeah.
But I've been busy.
We're going to bring it back though, right, Alan?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, Chode, if you want to play.
Oh, hell yeah.
We do like OG decks a lot of the time.
They're just like more fun and...
Goat netizens?
Yeah.
I was thinking of Rosalina before I get confused again.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to be Birdo.
No.
I'm going to be Waluigi.
Yeah, we just do like...
We do like a lot of the OG ones because it's just easier to follow.
We do goat decks, but like not even goat decks.
We do like anime decks, dude.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
I'm summoning out like Giant Soldier of Stone and like Beaver Warrior.
What?
And then I'll be the guy in the Dragon Knight or whatever.
But the reason I asked you about the Beaver Warrior thing, Chode, is because basically Beaver Warrior for me in sight became a meme.
He ended up buying me a PSA 10 one.
Oh, yeah.
Really?
I got scammed on that.
I think I paid double so I could get it in time for when you were visiting.
But like it was worth it though.
How much was a PSA 10 Beaver Warrior?
Well, I don't think it's... it's not worth as much as I paid for it.
But since I was getting it on like short notice, I paid like more than I... it was like a hundred something.
Which is like...
Okay.
All right.
It's a Beaver Warrior.
A lot more than it's worth.
I got scammed.
But you know, you got to pay for the speed of it because Elem was coming in from the UK.
Dude.
Honestly, I've got a gift.
Pause it out.
I was like, there's no fucking way.
Or maybe the price went up.
PSA 10 Beaver Warrior.
It has to.
The longer it goes, the more expensive it gets.
Wait, dude.
It went up.
Yes.
I mean, I hope so.
It's cost $200 on eBay now.
Damn.
Dude, Elem, your thing went up in price.
Oh, my God.
Elem, you should put the Beaver Warrior in your will.
What?
You need to put the Beaver Warrior in your will.
$30.
Yeah.
Probably like by the time you die, it might be $300.
Oh, shit.
But don't sell it, Elem, because that's selling like a part of your friendship.
You can't do that.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I mean, I guess I just give it back to Syke.
Wait.
I recently got a really cool new card.
Let me...
Dude, I can't even take a picture.
I'm using my phone for my...
Wait.
Did I not press A?
It was me.
Is it me?
No, it was me.
I think it's Elem now.
We're ready to go.
Oh, yeah.
Here we go.
You said you recently got a new card, though?
Yeah.
I got that cool Greninja card.
It's the coolest Greninja of all time.
Oh, okay.
Wait a second.
Was that the chase card?
From, like, a set ago?
It's actually a promo card.
It's the Ash Greninja?
Which makes it, like, less cool, but let me look for it.
Let me look for it.
Wait.
How much is it?
I'll show you the picture of the one I have.
I think it was, like, just under 200 for the PSA 10.
Oh, look at that thing.
Oh, that's cool.
Dude, this one is the coolest Greninja, like, ever, and I got a PSA 10.
Dude, I love the full art of Pokmon.
It's so good.
Same.
The problem is, though, like, some of the things that are cool, like, I don't know if they're full art cards, like, if you don't know much about them, you open it, and it looks like it's the coolest thing in the existence of history, and it's, like, a dollar.
Yeah.
Dude, that happens to me so often.
Dude, I got a golden card.
It was, like, solid gold.
Yeah!
And it's called, like, Jubilife City, and I was, like, dude, this thing's solid gold.
It's gotta be worth, like, tons.
Oh, I heard about those.
But they had to be...
I looked it up.
Yeah.
It was worth two bucks.
Because they made, like, a shitload of them.
It was so easy to pull.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was crazy.
I thought it was the coolest thing ever.
Oh, wait, that was, like, the one you could just buy from, like...
Yeah, you just buy it from, like, a collector's thing, and it just...
it's just there.
I mean, it's still a cool card, though.
I mean, it's, like, it looks dope as fuck.
Nice.
Oh, you weren't here for it earlier, but Elm said that he doesn't seem disinterested in us.
He's just nursing a sore throat.
Yeah.
But he promises he's having fun.
I know.
He's definitely disinterested.
I mean, he has to.
He organized this collab, so...
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm first.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Let's go, Waluigi!
Let's fucking go!
Wait, who's Mario?
You got...
I take a nine.
Yeah, I got...
I got ransacked, man.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I got third.
I mean, going first is such a big advantage to me.
He is the Mario Party Professionello, so it makes sense.
It makes sense.
Is he?
Dude, chill.
He's the Mario guy.
Yeah, that's...
He literally had a dongle on his Switch for the wired connection.
That's hardcore.
He's literally got a dongle.
Not a penis dongle.
He's in a dongle.
He's literally got the Mario...
Yeah, who the fuck does that for the Switch?
He's a dongler.
Who puts a dongler on the Switch?
I will tell you, when you're playing Mario Kart and some of those people you're playing against are really good, you need every advantage you can get.
Every advantage.
My friend, Tom, he'll come in.
We'll be doing a Mario Kart session.
He's not even in the session.
We'll be racing for, like, two hours.
He joins one game, dominates us, doesn't say anything, and then just leaves.
Like, that's the competition that we're having.
That's what Doki Bird does to us.
That's what Doki Bird does to me in Street Fighter.
He's jumping and just kicking ass.
But you kick jerk!
Look what happened!
You won in the end!
Yeah, until the finals when it lagged.
And then your luck ran out.
I didn't see you play in that.
How bad was it?
Like, how bad was your lag?
It was worse than the first.
Like, I just couldn't push anything.
Wait, really?
It was like a 60 frames lag input.
It was like almost a full second of lag, so I couldn't even block.
Like, it was...
Wait, really?
It was pretty bad.
Yeah.
Oh, dude.
That sucks.
This was in Street Fighter?
Yeah.
And then obviously playing a classic against modern when it's like that bad, I have to do like five inputs for one.
And with the lag, it's just not...
Yeah.
And like, he was playing as Blanka, who can just set up a ranged attack from like 200 miles away.
And the only way to defend is to jump over it or to parry it.
And obviously, I can't do it because it's just...
Humiliate.
Come on!
It almost feels like the Super Smash Brothers Online on the Switch.
Like, that has like a built-in one second delay.
And that's so frustrating because the Smash Brothers is so much fun.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, dude.
It's...
Playing fighting games, it's just not...
It's just not it.
I mean, with delay, like...
I mean, games in general.
Like, frame input and stuff, too.
Because like every...
Every input matters.
Dude, I was messing up my heavy punch, heavy kick combo.
It's just two buttons.
Yeah.
When I was watching your game, I was like, why the fuck is he like just backing up?
I was so confused.
I was like, why he doesn't want...
It's because I couldn't do anything.
He was crazy.
I was like, well, this is...
I was like, what's going on?
Okay.
So, if you guys are fighting game people, then you understand that Dead or Alive is not a booby game.
That is an intricate fighting game.
Correct?
Yes.
I've never played that game, but...
Oh, it's so good.
I've never played it, but like, I watch videos just for research.
Who's your favorite character in Dead or Alive?
Ryu Hayabusa and...
Ryu Hayabusa.
So, he's really cool.
That was...
That was instant.
That was such a fast reply.
I mean, he looks cool.
Yeah.
This dude looks kind of cool.
It's cool.
And then in DOA 4...
Wait.
Who's Rosalina?
Master Chief.
Master Chief is in Dead or Alive?
Yeah.
Dead or Alive 4.
Master Chief is in...
Does he wear like...
Wait.
Is he in the beach collection?
I mean, that's...
No, no, no.
He's in full armor.
Aww.
Then what's the point?
I don't know, man.
Like, why can't they put him in the beach collection?
If Master Chief comes out with double Ds, that'd be hilarious.
No.
I just want him in like Thawne.
Start it up, guys.
Start it up.
What's Dead or Alive?
Oh, it's a fighting...
It's a really good fighting game.
A real fighting game.
Legitimate.
It's not just a boobie game.
I've only played Street Fighter and Tekken.
Oh, Tekken's another fun one.
Who's Rosalina?
I love Tekken.
Guys, we have to work together, guys.
Guys, we have to...
It should be simple, guys.
Oh, no.
No one ever loses this one.
Guys, please.
We got him.
Dude, the delay is terrible.
What?
You're sitting on my face.
Please.
Guys, I'm...
Guys, there's no way we lose.
No one's ever lost this one.
I can't move.
The delay.
I got it.
You're welcome.
Oh, my God, dude.
That was close.
I almost had it.
That was the longest I've seen someone survive on that mode.
We're too busy talking about Dead or Alive.
Oh, my God.
Master Chief and the Banana Hammock coming out like Borat.
I need to write out who's who because I don't even know who's who.
Who?
What item did you get?
Oh, dude, you 100% want to use that item.
You could buy the star right now.
Wait, what did I get?
I looked away.
You just missed the star.
You're one away from the star now.
What if someone steals it?
There's no way.
Nobody's going to steal it, right?
Yeah, no.
Surely.
Guys, guys.
No.
All of you guys are going to steal it.
Oh, that's a great item to steal.
I tell you.
Guys, I looked away because I was trying to type out, like, who's who.
Oh, my God.
Guys, Ellum, if you steal that star from Doki, I'll buy you the extra hot para-o-meter from Nando's.
Oh, say less.
Say less.
I'm doing it.
Do that star, Doki?
Ellum, if you don't steal that, I will...
Oh, you said extra hot.
I'm going for it.
Extra hot from on the para meter.
So, all I got to do is roll a 10, as we were saying.
Yeah, 10.
Oh, shit.
What?
Holy Jesus.
Ellum, Ellum, if you don't steal...
He stole it for real.
What the...
Ellum, if you don't steal it, I will...
I will buy you something better than what Sykkuno was buying you.
No, Sykkuno's buying the para-o-chicken thingy.
Doki should have had that.
She should have had that.
Doki, I'll let you pitch your...
She literally had that.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, Sykkuno was giving you something that doesn't exist.
I'll give you something that does exist.
I'm getting Nando's.
Do you think you're going to beat Nando's for a British man?
He's buying me a Nando's.
I will buy you...
Do you want me to give you some Spudman?
I'll get you some Spudman.
The potato with beans and cheese.
How are you going to beat that?
I'll buy you two.
Two chickens at Nando's.
I bet you Sykkuno...
Two chickens?
Oh, I'll buy you a combo.
A full-on combo at Nando's.
In this economy?
A full combo?
Yeah, in this economy too.
Okay, Doki, if you can answer this question, what exactly is in a full combo, do you mind answering?
A full combo?
It'll have like...
It'll have the chicken.
It'll have the fries.
It'll have the beverage.
You can choose whatever beverage you want.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
She called them what?
You mean the chips?
Crips.
No.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
That's a king.
Yeah.
Yeah, get her.
They're chips.
She called them fries.
And they're perry soda chips while you're at it, actually.
I got a question for you, Elem.
Dude, I can't believe Doki actually didn't get that star.
I can't believe you got ten!
Dude, that's just evil that Elem stole that from you.
That's crazy.
I can't believe you got ten!
I'll do it again.
That's insane.
And it also doesn't stop there.
You literally had a mushroom.
I'm going to steal your money as well.
Thank you so much, Doki.
You're going to steal my money?
What did I do to you?
I literally just insisted.
I'm going to offer you things!
I really appreciate the free money, Doki.
Thank you so much.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, did you actually steal?
What makes you think you're going to win?
No, you didn't.
Oh, because guys, I'm the Mario guy.
You're the Mario guy?
I don't see no mustaches, shall I?
There's ten.
Oh, I've grown facial hair now, shall we?
Did he just roll the dice?
Each of us!
He robbed each of us!
You guys didn't even pay in full.
Look at this.
It's probably being pulled.
I put in 100% of my money proportionally.
We call this London style, guys.
London style robbery is what we call it.
That means he's going to stab us.
Yeah, he's going to stab us.
He's going to throw acid on our face.
I can't even do the voice.
I can't raise my voice.
Dude, this one's cooked.
I hate this dude.
Oh, dude.
How do you die?
How do I not get sucked?
Yeah.
Well...
How do I die?
I need you to die, Rose.
I need you to die.
Wait and down.
Oh, like that.
Okay.
You're gaming.
Oh, I'm doing it.
All right.
My turn.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Now I'm ready up.
Yeah, it's easy.
Dude, this is...
Yeah, this one's easy.
Okay, I'm locking it.
Guys, this is going to be a generational run.
If I lose this, I'm going to buy a chilled Yu-Gi-Oh box next time I see him.
Oh my God.
I don't know what if I win.
I'm just not even harder, but I have a messed-up Labrum.
What the hell is a Labrum?
Oh my God, you're laggling.
The Labrum is in your shoulder.
I'm dead.
It's laggling.
At last.
He's not going to take our ten dollars.
I'm mashing so hard, but I'm so slow.
The delay, guys.
I beat you.
My Labrum.
The delay.
I'm mashing really hard, too.
Yes!
Dude, okay.
Like, but I finished.
Does that count as a win?
You...
Yes.
Thank you.
You're very nice.
But like I finished, though.
Thanks, LM, for all that money.
Hey, Ndoki, I did that for you.
Yeah, yeah, after stealing the star right in front of me, yeah!
I did that for you.
So a labrum is in your shoulder, and I tore mine by doing burpees.
What the fuck is burpees?
So burpees are when you jump up and you jump on the ground to a push-up, push yourself back up, jump.
The funny thing is, I always call it a labia, that I tore my labia, and it always comes out.
Oh yeah, I thought it was a labia.
Wait, isn't it a labia for me?
No, no, I did not tear my labia.
I feel like you don't want to say that.
Wait, what's a labia?
I don't know if you want to say that.
LM, do you have a labia?
I don't know, do I?
What's a labia?
Yes or no, do you?
You think you have one.
You tore your labia.
Yep, so do you have one?
I do.
I guess so.
Guys, wait, what is a labia?
Man, I thought American school was bad.
No, that's just LM, Chill, that's just LM.
Oh, it's the vagina.
That's quite embarrassing, but it's okay, it happens to the best of us.
Anyway, yeah, I fucked mine up doing burpees.
Did you do your A levels?
Did you?
I did, but we just didn't do much on that part of the A.
The female anatomy, yeah.
Yeah, no, that's understandable.
I don't think it should be in the A levels, but like...
Dude, there's like certain things which I have learned over the last year, which people assume I know.
So you know in school you learn what vowels are?
Yeah, yeah, you didn't know what vowels are.
I didn't know what vowels were, right?
Because everyone assumes at that point you just know it.
So then I was like...
What are the vowels, man?
What are the vowels?
Yeah, what are vowels?
I know them now, because A, E, I, O, U, and sometimes Y is what I've been told.
But I cannot tell you what in the fuck a prime number is.
God damn it, no idea.
There's no way he doesn't know.
Dude, no idea what a prime number is, and I still can't tell you what it is.
He's a multi-millionaire streamer, doesn't know what a prime number is.
So you tell him someone held a gun to your head, and he said, What's a prime number, LM?
You die.
Then I accept death.
Why would you do this to him?
Augh, bro!
He just walked off!
Okay.
None of this makes any sense.
I take that.
I needed that win.
God damn.
Prime numbers are numbers that can't be broken into whole numbers.
So what the hell does that mean?
Wait, what did you get on math, LM?
On your As, on your A levels?
Well, I didn't do it for A levels.
I did it for, we did like GCSUs and then A levels.
Okay, that makes a lot of sense.
Name one prime number, now that you know what it is.
You got this.
Two.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Wait, why are we laughing?
Isn't that...
Wait, two is a prime number, I think.
I like how you're like, I think.
Is it not?
No, it's not a prime number.
Wait, two isn't a prime number?
Ain't no way, bro.
I have a degree in mathematics.
Wait, you have a degree in mathematics?
Yeah, I have a master's degree in statistics.
Wait, you have a master's degree?
Master's degree?
Yeah, I used to have a regular job before I was streaming.
Oh my gosh.
Me too, I used to work at a comic book store.
And they would pay me off the books when I was 14.
Which I think is highly unethical and illegal.
I don't think the comic book store is there anymore.
But if you can, you could call the IRS on it.
They wouldn't even pay me cash.
They would pay me in Yu-Gi-Oh!
packs.
Dude, that's better.
Yeah, that's better though.
I swear to God, that's exactly what I got paid for.
Dude, that's better.
I used to work at a horse store and it was fucking terrible.
You get a BLS Envoy of the End?
That's money back then.
No, you have to...
How do you know that?
Because I literally pulled...
So I'm not even joking.
So there was one night we were doing...
I'm cleaning up, so my job was to host Yu-Gi-Oh!
card tournaments and clean up the shop on Fridays.
And I got paid four Yu-Gi-Oh!
packs.
And one of those nights, I pulled a BLS Envoy of the Beginning and a Chaos Emperor Dragon Envoy of the End.
In my four packs.
Oh shit!
Yelling.
It was incredible.
I still have those cards.
Oh my God, this was before, like...
Why didn't you sell it?
You would have been rich.
Yeah, you could have sold it.
You should have sold it.
They turned it into a promo card after that and it was worthless.
Oh, is that what happened?
Wait, so does that mean...
Yeah, they made a promo version of BLS, which made it worth, like, a lot less after that.
They do a lot of reprinting and it hurts.
Does the original lose value after it gets reprinted or not?
So, I wouldn't say the original loses all of its value.
It loses a good amount of value, but people want cards that are from, like, certain sets.
So if it's, like, an old card that gets reprinted, it'll probably still retain its value.
But if it's a newer card that gets reprinted...
it is not going to retain its value at all.
It's just going to die.
Oh, that sucks.
Yeah, it does kind of suck.
So there's no point in buying meta cards if, like, you're trying to collect them.
At least while they're new.
Because they will just drop from $100 down to $10 over the course of a year.
It just happens every single time.
Fuck that.
Coney Island.
Let's go.
We gotta catch the ice cream.
Oh, we gotta catch the ice cream.
With the lag, this is gonna be good.
With the delay, this is actually impossible.
I can't do this.
This is just...
Like, there's...
Dude, I can't even...
We should have been dongled, guys.
We should have been dongled.
The lag is really bad on this one.
I was the only person who didn't get a single scoop then.
That's insane.
Come on, give me a scoop.
Give me a scoop.
Move.
Get out of the way.
Thank you, guys.
Hey, you guys have been crushed.
Thanks.
Thanks, Sykuno.
They're taking everything.
You guys have been crushed.
There's not enough spawning.
Sykuno, you gotta stop competing with me for spots.
Yes.
Oh, no.
I wasn't even trying to.
I was here first.
You guys were there first.
You get a little heavier.
Guys, I...
It's lagging.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
I was there.
I was gonna sit here.
I'm gonna sit here.
I think I clearly won.
I would really like to have...
Dude, I think I had a chance.
I have a chance.
So, guys...
Oh, we tied.
Let's go.
I didn't get one.
I literally didn't get one.
So, that feels great.
Dude, I'm not plugged in.
My delay.
I got two coins.
That's something.
Dude, why am I so broke?
What the...
Because you spent money on a star.
You're in first place.
You're literally first place.
What are you?
Undreamed?
You son of a bitch.
Can't believe.
We're playing against Guild Chaos, guys.
You're gonna end up with ten stars by the end of this, okay?
I'm 41 spaces away from a star.
Actually, Doki, what you can do is since you have that card, when you get to a star, you can buy two of them at one time.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm hoping for too.
Which is pretty nice.
Which means you have to buy the treasures against you.
When does the shop get super juiced again?
Is that a British thing?
Can you say that again?
I'm gonna get a chomp card.
When does the shop get super juiced?
Like with the better items and stuff.
Oh, okay.
When do they get new inventory?
Yeah, yeah.
Why would you buy a chomp card?
You have to throw away an item.
Yeah, I don't need the mushroom.
I have two mushrooms.
God dang.
If you used that mushroom last time, you would have had a star.
And another item?
True.
You throw the mushroom away again.
Oh.
Honestly, at this point, you don't even need mushrooms.
What is this?
Custom dice can pop.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't think I need the mushroom.
Get rid of that thing.
Get it out of here, man.
Get it out of here.
I'm gonna get rid of that.
I don't think I need it.
I know what's gonna happen.
I love that you have five items and then the rest of us are sitting here with one and zero.
Yeah, or none.
I'm just...
This is what happens to me, dude.
I roll well and then I start rolling zero.
Oh, no.
Yeah, but I don't want...
Okay, give me coins.
Give me coins.
Oh, we got ten coins, though.
Maybe, Elif, if you start winning games, you get coins.
Oh, this next game.
Okay.
This next game.
If I could just roll an eight here, that would be... that would just really make my day, you know?
Son of a...
Ooh.
All right, just six more.
Just six more.
Just surely.
Hey.
Hey, maybe you'll get an item, too.
More money.
Yeah, maybe.
Can I get an item, more money, or an item back?
Wait.
Oh, dude.
Item bag would be crazy here.
You know what would be crazy?
If I use...
Oh!
Dude, no way.
Well, that's good for you, though.
Yeah, it's good.
Don't say it, Doki.
You're gonna go to hell if you say it.
Doki, do it.
Do it, Doki.
Do it.
You're gonna go to hell, Doki.
Hit him with a Trump Cool Doki.
I did this.
Ah.
There's so many better times to use it.
Hit him with a Trump Cool Doki.
Do it.
Oh, my God.
Wouldn't it be funny if you get double ones?
Wouldn't that be...
Oh, four?
It would be less than five.
Oh!
Three?
Oh, my God.
Hey, maybe you can get a Chomp Call and use it next game.
Yeah, get another one.
Get another Chomp Call.
Screw it.
Yeah.
Get a Chomp Call.
Why not?
Yeah, just do it.
Get one.
Get another Chomp Call.
I'm getting a Skeleton Key, okay?
Because I need this.
Wait, guys.
He's one of those players.
He's a Skeleton Key player.
Dude, he's trying to steal.
Who the fuck uses a Skeleton Key?
He's gonna steal from King Boo.
We all know the plan.
He's gonna steal everything.
He's trying to trick us.
No, guys.
I'm a friend.
We should all gang up and chill.
Hey, Trey.
Have I ever told you that you were my favorite creature back then?
He's stealing from all of us.
He doesn't even have a choice, I think.
Now that you've said that, he's probably gonna target you on purpose.
Those were some good times, man.
You know, besides getting kicked out and everything.
It was a real good time.
Yeah, but I was so mad when you got kicked out when I was in school.
When I saw that, I was like, how fucking fair.
Exactly.
I stopped watching the creatures when they kicked out.
I said the creatures more like the Cringers.
Yeah.
I walked away and I said, never again.
Oh, that's for money.
We can all get money.
Yeah, this doesn't work for me.
I always suck at this one.
Oh, sorry.
I said we.
You guys always win here, just to be clear.
Oh.
Wait.
We're just...
Yeah, so...
Look, he just kills me.
Like, how do you not die in this?
You just walk the other way.
Yeah, me too.
Just turn the computer off.
Okay.
Surely.
Wee.
Oh, I need that money.
Get that cash.
Wait, which way am I walking?
Get the bag.
Elm, get the bag, bro.
I can't.
Grab the money, guys.
Grab the money.
Elm, why are you getting so close to me, dude?
Elm, get the bag, dude.
Elm, you're fumbling the bag.
Spread out.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I got it.
Get the bag.
Get the bag, quick.
Quick, get the bag.
I got money.
I got the money.
Yes.
Okay.
We got to spread out.
Elm.
I'm spreading as much as I can.
I got literally as spread as I can be.
Hold strong.
I have some cash for you guys.
Hold strong, guys.
Hold strong.
Okay.
All right.
I got some.
Wait, you guys did good.
I did shit.
Okay.
I think I got like 60% of that.
Oh, no.
I got more than that.
I got like one bag.
I got like one coin.
I'm going to be so real.
Oh, wait.
I got 36 coins.
No, we all got 36 together.
It's a team game.
Oh.
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
All right.
Yay.
I can use my item.
Oh, yeah.
Don't chomp call, please.
Yay.
Think of all the good old days.
Think of the good old days when we used to play games.
Yes.
Very good.
I'm thinking about the good old days right now where I chomp call over there.
Think of Elem when he stole your star.
Oh, I hope.
Yeah, shouldn't we be talking Elem in first place?
Shouldn't we be like, oh, guys.
Guys.
Wait.
What is this?
It's okay.
You guys can all chomp call.
Wait.
Who's second?
It's right in front of Chilled.
It's literally in front of Chilled.
Oh.
Okay.
Guys.
We can all just chomp call together, guys.
Oh, I got one.
Okay.
Let's go.
Yeah, but seeing as I was kicked out of the creatures, don't you guys feel bad and just let me have it?
No.
It's right there.
Yeah, but that was like 10 plus years ago.
So, like, time moves on.
We forgot about that now.
Guys.
Guys, like, the wound that you've just opened in my heart hurts more.
Dude, why do I keep rolling so freaking low now?
Like, what is this?
Okay.
Here we go.
Come on.
Give me more coins.
No.
Well, I know exactly where I'm giving this to.
Dude, you gotta use it on Doki.
Okay.
You got it.
Chomp call.
You know you want to.
You gotta chomp call, man.
You gotta do it.
Get rid of it quick.
But you have a heart.
You're different from these other people.
I know what it felt like to get chomp called when it was right in front of me.
Yeah.
I can't do that to him.
It just happened to me.
No, hurt people don't hurt people.
Yeah, but what if he does that to you?
But what if I chomp call it and it appears in front of me, though?
Yeah, exactly.
Like, what if I chomp call it and it appears in front of me and then the world is right again, you know?
You're making me unhappy for a chance to make you happy?
This is guaranteed me unhappiness.
Remember what Saikuro did to you.
He got rid of it.
Well, no.
I did this because Doki did this.
Dude, I'm making a list at this point.
He dialed us the orange.
That's mine.
This could be mine.
Doki would cause all this.
That's mine.
That's true.
You know what?
You're right.
And if you had got that one, it probably would move to my spot and no one even had to use a change shot.
Yeah, but then, but then, the only reason why I did this was because Ellum took the first star.
Oh, so now we're blaming Nina.
Oh, we do hate Ellum again.
Yeah.
Blame Nina.
Blame the guy who can't speak properly.
So this is all Ellum's fault.
Yeah, this is all Ellum's fault.
Blame the guy who can't speak properly.
This is all Ellum's fault.
We're going to do a funny chomp call again.
It makes sense.
Wait, Sakuna.
I agree.
Do you want this cast, iSports Sakuna?
Because it's got, it's got your name written all over it.
It's a psycho.
Honestly, if you use it, it'll help me, actually.
Oh, money.
Didn't need money.
Yeah, because that'll get me closer to landing on that bank.
That's true.
Oh, two times coins.
This is a big one.
Two eggs.
Double mini coin game.
Okay.
X-ray payday.
It'll be 40 coins for us.
Boomba spotting.
Oh, it's counting time.
I can't count.
Okay.
Chat time.
Tell me how to, tell me the right answer, chat.
How do I?
You just gotta count?
Yeah, you just gotta count.
You click every time.
Yeah, and the crazy one is, you don't know what you're, and you don't know what you're at or anything.
This one's a difficult one.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
I've actually got a strap for this.
I actually have a strap.
I think you can't go down either.
You can't.
You can only count.
Here we go.
You ready?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
I have to click.
Oh, I haven't been clicking one time.
I fucked up.
There's no way.
Dude, I'm just randomly clicking at this point.
I don't know what I'm on.
I just...
Is it usually like a high number?
How many times have you clicked?
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
Wait, you guys are still spamming?
Wait.
I've just been spamming this whole time.
I'm not even thinking about it.
Wait.
Oh.
What the hell?
You're at 48.
How are you at 48?
Dude, was it 38?
Dude, it was 38, 100%.
Oh, no.
I think we nailed it.
I think we fucking nailed it.
Oh, no.
I did one extra click.
No.
I did an extra click.
48.
I don't know how he got 48, but...
That's so awesome.
Oh, yeah.
We call that British math.
British math, guys.
I mean, to be fair, he was like trying to do random numbers thinking that's how it works in a clicking game.
Honestly, my thing made no sense because they know, like, how would they know the number?
Yeah, I don't know why I was doing that.
That was stupid.
Yeah.
But the good thing is you were definitely naming some prime numbers in the beginning.
Yeah, yeah.
That was good.
That was nice.
Yeah, I was.
Prime numbers is a good thing.
Maybe prime numbers has come natural to me now, you know?
Yeah, you're learning.
Well, thank God for that.
Finally.
Elam, I want to see you in the service industry where it's like the bill's $30 and you're like, I'll take 40.
That's fine.
I would love to see how it works.
Oh, my God.
Well, Elam did used to work at Hollister.
I used to work at Hollister.
Yeah.
But how old were you when you worked at Hollister?
You were the model or were you the cashier?
I would just like...
I kind of worked in the store.
So I wasn't like... they had like the term as model, but I wasn't like a model.
It's just like a cringe thing.
They would like call you.
But it wasn't like that.
Did you have to wear like tight shirts on purpose or like...
Oh, damn.
We would have to wear tight shirts.
Yeah.
Dude, Elam's kind of a gigachat.
I'm not a gigachat.
I'm not.
Now that you can switch in here too, dude.
I mean, like, he's not like a gigachat in the video games, but like in real life, though, he's tall.
He works out.
Oh.
Whoa.
Why are you acting surprised?
You're the one working out.
Oh, no.
I appreciate you gassing me up.
This is nice.
Yeah.
Of course.
That's my guy.
That's my guy right there.
The D1 of glazing right now.
Keep it up.
Yeah.
That's when you know he's a bro.
Like, he's gonna still like... he won't let you win in video games, but at least he's gassing you up.
Yeah.
Dude, when we were on our Tekken phase, man, I think I got like a 30 win streak on him and he was going crazy.
Oh, dude.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Sorry, people started saying I sound like a lawnmower because I was just like, I was just growling by the end.
It was just like...
Ellum, we gotta win.
Ellum, I believe in you.
Ellum, we...
You should not.
You should not believe in me.
Ellum, please.
We gotta...
We got this.
We got...
Ellum.
Please.
No way.
We're locked in.
Please, you got locked in.
I'll go left.
You go right.
Which was...
Okay.
Ellum, please.
Ellum.
Oh, we are crushing them.
They are done.
Please.
Dude, we are locked.
Wait.
We did it.
Okay.
Yes.
I'll go the other direction that you're going.
Okay.
We should have been given that one.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
Me and Shield.
I'm going up to the...
Yeah.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, my God.
I went too high.
I need you to...
Wait.
Ellum, I need you to work with me.
Hey, you know what?
We should do more team games.
This was too easy.
Oh, my God.
Dude.
Me and Shield.
Destroy.
I already need you to actually get it together.
All right, guys.
Who wants Ellum as a teammate, guys?
Next game.
I'm so embarrassed.
But, Ellum, at least you're first.
Ellum, at least you're first.
Everything.
Everything went wrong.
Dude, Ellum is the best.
Ellum is in first place, though.
I feel like...
Yeah, Ellum.
Ellum.
Everything went wrong.
You're still on first place.
Dude, I want to point out that Doki was just following me the whole time.
That was...
Oh, yeah.
I was walking the opposite direction of you.
I was literally...
Every time I try to walk in the opposite direction of you, you keep fucking following me.
You guys got to start 12 and 6 and just circle around, guys.
Guys, who's going to do the next chomp call?
We're getting closer to it.
I have so much money.
I just need it.
Wait.
What items do I...
I've got a cursed dice block.
Wait.
Now, who would like this?
Which one of my friends would enjoy this?
Well, Skuno gets a chance at the bank, which is nice.
I didn't get a chance at the bank, but Chilled sounds like he's worried about getting it.
Yeah, Chilled, you do sound a little concerned.
Oh, just a tiny bit.
He sounds a little stressed out.
The thing is, Chilled, with me, I'd always rather go for the more chaotic option, which unfortunately is...
Which means Doki worth it.
Which means it's...
Wait.
I was going to press Doki.
I'm just sorry.
Oh, wow.
What happened?
You poisoned me at the damn late daughter's wedding?
What the fuck is this?
That's crazy.
Dude, he just got chomp called when he was right in front of the star.
Now you do that.
He's right in front of the next star, too.
That's the worst part.
We're together now, Chilled.
He's even worse.
Dude, I thought that was Doki.
I'm so sorry.
That's just evil, man.
He just got chomp called and lost the star.
Now you're going to do that?
That's evil.
Dude, why did you choose Mario?
I thought you were freaking...
I am Mario.
You lose track of me?
How did you forget he was Mario?
How the fuck did you get the money anyway?
No, I got the bank anyway.
No, not bad.
Not bad.
I literally said earlier, I was like, oh, Chilled even has the eye on Mario moustache, and I still fucking forgot.
I can't believe you got confused between Waluigi and Mario.
Like, one is tall and the other is short.
I bet you don't even care that you got kicked out of the creatures.
I bet you were fucking happy when it happened.
Yeah.
I don't know what the creatures is.
I'm going to say, I don't know.
He doesn't even know what the creatures are.
He's not OT.
Where were you 13 years ago?
How dare you not remember something 13 years ago?
I don't even know what I even watched 13 years ago.
I'm going to say it.
I don't...
I think I...
I remember what I watched.
Yeah, I remember.
I used to watch Minecraft YouTuber Let's Players.
Oh, like who?
I used to watch...
I used to watch Cod Montages back in the day.
Yeah, dude.
I used to watch like those...
Dude, I used to watch C9ers back in the day when like he would do his CSGO things and shit.
Wait, so you remember C9ers?
But no.
You're not chilled?
Wow.
Not the same group.
Dude, that's...
Me and Shannon played so much together.
We played for years together.
Does anyone remember Paperbat though?
Anyone remember Paperbat VG?
No, he died.
That's actually crazy.
He died.
Wait, my chat said you used to...
I even saw his cooking video.
You can use...
Wait, chilled?
We used to work on a Disney show.
No, the golden one ran out.
I used to work on a Disney show.
Oh, my God.
The delay.
He used to do stuff with nanners.
The fact that you didn't see nanners, that's crazy.
Bro, I don't even like Alan.
Can I say that?
No, Junkyard was right.
When Junkyard said that you were a pain in the ass, he was so right.
I mean, I'm not even going to fight it.
Holy shit.
Hey, we got tied.
If they saw a nanners cooking video, you're literally in that video.
I'm in a nanners cooking video?
Yeah.
I think you're just like, I am?
I am?
I don't remember.
Dude, when you think about like all the nanners, you're literally in that video.
All the content that we've done over the last 10, 15 years, I don't...
Someone tells me I could have done something like that.
Sounds about right.
Yeah, probably.
You've been a con curator since 2008.
I'd be surprised if you remember everything.
2008 is crazy.
Well, some of the great things are like, I'll go back and watch some of my older videos and be like, ah, this guy's pretty funny.
You know?
And that's always nice when you go back and can make yourself laugh.
Put a smile on my face.
Hey, let's go.
Yeah, really.
It's like an old...
I went through some of my old YouTube videos from like, maybe like five years ago.
And they're just horrible.
Dude, they're like OG, like old school Fortnite updates and they're the most cringe shit I've ever seen.
Oh my God.
The Fortnite update.
That's funny.
They are so bad.
And then I found out the other day...
When did I find out?
I...
Someone...
I used to...
Okay.
Back in the day, I used to make like fitness YouTube videos.
Did you just clap at us?
Did you literally just clap at us?
Really?
Can you send us a link to it?
No, no.
I got rid of all the videos.
They don't exist.
They're over the channel.
What?
Why?
Why not?
Because dude, they're cringe as fuck.
What do you mean?
It's so funny.
Hey, it's LM here.
I'm going to show you how to get ripped in 10 easy steps.
Wait, how did you do your intro?
What was your intro like?
What was your intro?
Yeah.
I can't even do...
Because I can't raise my voice.
I can't do it.
No, it's okay.
Do the Monotone version.
Let's try it.
Just one extreme shot, dude.
Just one.
Dude, I can't...
No, okay.
Did Doki just buy two stars in one turn?
Yeah, just buy two.
Yeah, exactly.
That's right.
Dude, the about section...
She's treating.
The about section said...
This is the...
It said, good vibes and live life.
Dude, you are on everything.
You're on every white girl's wall in the background.
Good vibes, dude.
Oh, my God.
It's insane.
Dude, the name of it was Project Aesthetics.
Oh, my God.
Project Aesthetics.
Wait, did you default delete it or did you just private it?
Oh, no.
The channel's there.
The videos are not on the other hand.
Wait, but is it a full delete or unlisted?
Dude, I wish they were.
I would watch it.
Yeah.
I didn't know that'd be it.
Good vibes, man.
Good vibes, bro.
Good vibes.
Good vibes and live life, dude.
I actually want to...
How old were you when you wrote that?
How old were you?
Like 21, 22.
It wasn't...
I wasn't even like young.
You're not even like...
I've got all of life figured out.
Oh, God.
And then I would do this...
I had this Instagram page where I would...
Dude, I did an entire post on the benefits of green tea.
Like, what the fuck am I doing?
The benefits?
So, what are the benefits of green tea?
Green tea is good for you.
Green tea is good for you?
It is good for you.
But just...
But it's just the fact like...
Yeah.
I don't know.
I...
No.
Because the picture was just a picture of a soggy teabag.
Oh, fuck.
So, it wasn't even like authentic green tea.
It wasn't even like a...
No.
It was just like...
It was green tea.
We've got two stars.
Oh.
Oh, I'm winning.
Oh, we're doing it.
He doesn't even notice he's winning.
He's just going with the flow.
What are we doing down here?
I'm just...
I'm in with the vibes.
Dude, me and Chill, they're at the bottom of the barrel fighting for our lives right now.
Yeah, but Chill has a plan.
We're cash rich, though.
We are cash rich.
Chill has a plan.
He's going to win with the...
Like, the bonus stars.
Can I ask you guys a question?
Yeah.
Sure.
So, have any of any of you guys ever tried to, like, test out whether you could sing or not?
I thought you were going to say something else.
I really thought you were going...
Did you try to suck your own dick?
I really thought you were going to go there.
I'm so sorry.
What?
I thought that's where he was going.
Chill.
I feel like...
I mean...
I could see Elm doing that.
I could try to suck your own dick.
Wait.
Suck your own dick?
You need to remove a rib for that.
After the live life thing, dude.
Nah.
I don't know anymore.
Yeah.
I say live life.
Good vibes.
Then I don't proceed to try and suck my own dick.
Yeah.
Good vibes.
You know?
Oh, God.
Love yourself.
Yeah.
So, have you guys ever, like, tried to see if you could sing or not?
By, like, recording yourself?
Well, I have to.
I had to as a VTuber.
Oh, I never recorded myself.
I tried.
Realized I sucked.
I, um...
I, uh...
I recorded myself.
Right?
Yeah.
And I didn't realize I sucked.
I didn't realize until, like, maybe, like, a few weeks ago that I actually still have the recordings.
Um...
How old are you?
Why don't you just sing right now?
Maybe, like, I was like, I can't.
I can't.
But, like, what I can do is play...
Sing us Maroon 5.
I can play you guys one of the recordings if you would like.
Oh, yeah.
Play it.
Well, let me find it.
Okay.
Sure.
Is it gonna hurt?
Okay.
Is it good or so bad that I'm shocked he's showing it to us?
Dude, no, no.
I'm real...
But you feel confident about showing this.
Like, this is something you want to show us.
Yeah, yeah.
You can hear it.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Yo, but you're confident showing it to us.
So, like...
One day we need to talk.
He walks.
You said sit down.
It's just...
Where's your accent?
Smiles politely.
Sorry, Bob.
Wait.
Your accent disappeared.
Like...
You were here.
This depressing song is making me depressed.
Wait.
Listen.
Wait for the drop.
Wait.
Oh, please.
First start.
What the...
This song is how to save a life that's having the complete opposite effect.
I wonder if we'll get DMCA'd for that.
I don't think so.
Honestly, if you did, that'd be, like, a big compliment.
That would be a big compliment.
Yeah, that would be a big compliment that you were...
Dude, who's pushing me?
Why?
I don't think so.
I don't understand.
I wasn't even moving.
I was so peaceful.
I was so peaceful chilling there.
I need my $10.
I just got pushed to my death.
Why?
We did it, guys.
We did it.
We all lost.
Wait.
Everybody loses.
Now we all have to pay.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
What?
Dude, I got Ed Sheeran on there.
There's one of me rapping as well.
It's like, dude, I try all avenues of my vocal potential.
It turns out I suck at them all.
I can't lie.
I got some cringe videos.
I got HeyThereDelilah somewhere on my YouTube channel.
Oh, shit.
You do?
Yeah, I want to hear that one.
That one's fun.
You shouldn't.
Definitely shouldn't.
Oh.
Wait.
How many views does it have?
I don't even know.
I don't even know, man.
Don't even look at it.
It's been years since I've looked at it.
Is it still public?
Or is it, like, privated?
I don't even know, man.
I think somebody might have downloaded it and re-uploaded it.
Wait.
Why did you private it?
Because it was horrific.
Why?
No.
Let it out.
Let the cringe free.
Let the cringe free?
Yeah.
See, cringe is cool now in 2024.
It's cool now.
But cringe wasn't cool in 2015.
Dude, I remember when I used to make COD montages back in the day, and some of my friends in school found it, and I never felt more embarrassed in my entire life.
It was terrible.
Dude, we should play Black Ops Zombies 6.
Oh, my God.
I miss zombies.
Yeah, dude.
Dude, we should play the new zombies.
Yeah.
I heard the new Black Ops is really good.
Do you want to play it?
Yeah.
I'm fucking down.
Wait.
When's it coming out?
It's not super long.
Is it next month?
November, right?
Early November?
I think it's next month.
Yeah.
Next two months.
Next month.
Yeah, dude.
I'll play that.
Fuck yeah.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
I fucking love zombies.
Dude, I feel like...
When was the last zombies game they did?
I feel like it's been a long time, right?
Well, there was the whole hacking situation that they had, too.
Hacking situation?
Oh.
Remember?
They had the whole situation where hackers were going in, can hack into people's lobbies and stuff.
So people stopped doing it.
Black Ops.
I don't remember that at all.
They did that from zombies?
Okay.
Can you guys stop being cringe?
Please leave me alone.
Thank you so much.
We're coming over.
We're going to get you.
You told it.
You told actually fuck off.
Okay.
Here we go.
Sorry.
Maybe I'll fuck off if you tell me a cartoon character you had a crush on.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I won't crush you.
Johnny Bravo.
Johnny Bravo?
Get the fuck over here.
Wait.
Are you serious?
A cartoon character I actually had a crush on?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, so you lied.
So we're definitely going to crush you now.
Wait.
I'm too quick.
Oh, dude.
He's fast.
He's good.
He's...
Oh.
We're cornering him.
No.
We almost got him.
Get him in the corner.
Let's try.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Dude, he's juking like crazy.
Holy shit.
Why did he get so good with the lag?
He's cracked.
Dude, how is he doing this with the lag?
Yes.
Oh, my God.
He won.
Dude, I just stalled in the middle of this shoot.
Dude, I was going to win the whole dang game.
Holy shit, dude.
This is my game.
This is actually my game right now.
The delay.
Oh, my God.
This is the first time he's ever won.
Holy crap.
I don't think I've ever won Mario Kart.
Yeah.
That's literally his first mini game win.
This is my game right now.
Oh, dude.
I broke their ankles, chat.
I broke their ankles.
All right.
Let's see.
Is anybody close to the star?
I wish he got 16 turns to catch up.
Let's see.
Who's the closest?
Oh, LM is.
Does he have enough coins?
Oh, he doesn't.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, we got coins.
Wait.
We got coins.
No, you don't.
Wait.
No.
No, I don't.
No, you don't.
You have fucking 16.
Turns out I'm a liar.
So, like, I don't have to worry.
This isn't Among Us.
You can't lie.
You're not allowed to.
Yeah, it turns out I'm a liar.
Shit.
Oh, my God.
People lie on the internet?
Just like that?
You like lying in Among Us?
Okay.
Go up north.
It's so much better for you.
Can you go up that way?
Oh, wait.
Yeah.
If you're in the daytime, you can.
But I don't want to.
I just want to.
I just want to walk this way.
You just want to pay your taxes?
That's such a good solution.
I just want to pay taxes.
Guys, I don't want the Canadian IRS to come over.
All right.
That's what the Mounties say.
Yeah.
One star could change my life.
Just one-time star.
Guys, last time me and Syke played this, I've actually never seen Syke crash out, but he crashed the fuck out of this game.
Dude, it's a 25-turn game, and I got zero stars.
Which was insane.
It was actually unbelievable.
He's never the sort of person just to leave a call, but the game finished, he just insta-left.
Thanks, guys.
I got to go.
Well, that was because I had a collab.
Dude.
I really loved it.
It was so fun.
It was like...
Zero stars in the entire match.
Technically, that was just because I had a collab after, but it did work out.
It did work out that way.
Did you not have bonus stars?
Damn, Doki, you're really going all in on them.
Because, like, usually the game would feel bad if you're like, since this guy has zero stars, we'll give him a bonus star.
Nah, drag him.
Let's see her more.
Hey, why don't you just keep attacking him?
Oh, my God.
It's my turn.
I wasn't even paying attention.
It was just...
I'm just reliving the trauma.
One star?
Why am I trying to go here?
Where am I?
Yeah.
I mean...
Let me view board real quick.
You do...
Oh, does no one have a charm card?
Dude, I'm getting that.
I'm getting that, bro.
You can't.
No, I think just you.
I think just you, Doki.
You can't get it because...
I'm going to go up and take the eyeball.
Oh, unless you guys...
Wait.
How far?
I look like I won't win any games.
I'll just have no money.
Are you preying on my downfall?
And I just get this star.
No, I'm just saying that you don't have the money yet to buy it.
She's calling you a broke boy.
Yeah.
What the hell?
Why are you calling me broke?
I'm not calling you broke.
I'm calling you middle class.
Oh.
And I'll just...
All right.
I'll take that.
Hired the seven this time, game.
We can do it.
I didn't know.
I was like, thanks, I guess.
Okay.
I'll take it.
Oh, a humble 11.
Okay.
Yes.
Of course, I must pay my taxes for...
I am a good citizen.
Pay your taxes, everybody.
Or the IRS is going to come over.
Never.
I don't know why they don't say thanks for your cooperation.
What a mistake.
How do you get the money from that again?
Are you going to land on it, right?
Like directly or something?
Yeah.
God damn it.
Well, you're not going to unlock it.
You have two keys.
I know, but it's a daytime ghost.
Yeah.
Oh.
The bottom left is a daytime ghost.
Oh, wait.
It is.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I forgot about that.
Oh.
Custom block?
Buy a chomp call.
Nothing short of an expert gamer.
He knows he is.
Buy a chomp call so like Elem can't get the other star.
I'm not going to use my skeleton key.
He knew the whole game.
Well, guys, guys, we don't need to target me here, guys.
I'm just an innocent, innocent guy, you know?
Yeah, but if you get the star, you get first place.
But Doki's also on two stars, guys.
But isn't it nice that we should all be having someone to go against?
It feels like it would fuel us and unite us to become an enemy.
Yeah, that's so true.
I believe that.
Aren't we all going against Elem?
Is that how you think?
Yeah.
Well, I mean...
We're all going, ganging up on Elem.
Wasn't that...
Yeah, that was...
Wasn't that the original plan?
But I'm an ally, guys.
Sounds like a great plan.
But I'm an ally.
Guys, I'm a big fan.
I'm an ally.
Dude, I hate this game.
Wait, how do you...
Dude, with the delay, this one is...
Oh, my God.
The delay for this is crazy.
The delay is...
No, and it stumbles, too?
Dude, I remember the one time I played baseball, I dislocated my thumb.
How?
Wait, what...
What position did you play?
Is it the ball?
Well, I was the...
What do you call it?
The batter?
Yeah, it would be the batter.
No, that's correct.
That's correct.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The guy pitched the ball and it just hit me straight in the thumb.
This is terrible.
Oh, did you...
Was the delay...
Were you able to walk the plate?
Were you...
Wait, because they broke your right finger?
Did you walk the plank?
Walk the plank?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, were you able to walk, like, the field?
I never played baseball, by the way.
Did you guys ever play rounders?
What the fuck is a rounders?
Oh, rounders is that shooting game.
Yeah, right?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, like the shooting game.
Wait, what is rounders?
It's so difficult.
Wait, wait, wait.
Did you guys ever play tiddlywinks?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's a Harry Potter game.
That's not real.
I played tiddlywinks.
It's a sport.
You guys ever played tiddlywinks?
It's like with beanbags.
Yeah, yeah.
You have to throw beanbags at each other.
Oh.
Guys, I...
My phone is covering my screen, by the way.
That's why I can't see.
I can't see either.
This is...
Am I winning?
Oh, wow.
I am.
My game is trash.
This game is actually...
I hate this game.
This game is thinking...
Like, what...
How did Chilled get 13?
What is this, man?
What is this?
Chilled doesn't have the delay, I swear.
I swear, did you plug your dongle back in, Chilled?
He has the dongle.
He has the dongler.
There's no...
He's got the dongle on.
He's got the dongle.
I want to point out, Chilled was silent during the whole thing.
Bro was dialed the fuck in.
Yeah, he was.
He really needed that minigame win.
He's not lagging at all.
I know, but I have to...
I got a win via bonus stars, because there's no way with you bastards calling the game the chop calls and everything else at night, we're going to be free.
Speaking of chop calls...
I have zero stars too, man.
I'm dying out here.
I think I'm going to spend the 150 on the big guy, because you don't even have a star to steal.
It would be wasteful.
Bye.
Oh, yeah, but you could just steal everything.
Oh.
You could steal everything.
Be right in front of me.
Be right in front of me for once in my sad life.
Is it right in front of you?
Down south.
Come down south.
Please be in me.
Oh, it's down there.
I don't want you to be in me.
For once in my sad life.
God is cruel.
It's right in front of me, right?
No, it's definitely not.
It's right in front of me.
Finally.
Wait, where am I?
Dude, are you on the map?
Finally, it's right in front of me.
Ah, depression.
Where even am I?
I don't think this is in front of me.
I think this is actually really far away from me.
It is.
It is very far away.
Oh, Doki.
Doki, do your double...
Oh, the double dice roll, Doki.
No, I couldn't.
I already used an item.
Oh, you're right.
You used chain shot.
My bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, what if we chop call this away from Doki?
How do you feel about that?
Chop call now.
What if I buy another...
Oh, I can't.
Do it.
I can't buy another chop call.
Do it now.
But I could buy a mushroom.
We need a chop call.
Can I show you guys my sexy voice?
Oh, yeah.
What is it?
I've been working on it.
Okay.
This is my sexy voice.
This is how I flirt with all the ladies.
Thoughts?
Out of 10?
Oh, wow.
Does it work?
Did it work?
No, never.
It's actually never worked once.
I don't think...
That's two of us, man.
I think you mean...
How long have you been trying to use that voice for?
How many years?
Yeah, I've been using this voice since 2008.
Wait.
Oh, wow.
But it sounds...
I love it.
It sounds great.
Oh, yeah.
But I heard you singing.
So I don't know if I trust you.
You might lose a star.
Oh, my God.
That was savage, dude.
It sounds just like...
Oh, my God.
You could do...
You could find somebody that really likes Barney.
Wait.
That does sound like Barney.
Yeah.
It sounds just like Barney.
It does sound like Barney.
Yeah.
I guess Barney's not really sexy these days.
Oh, no.
What is that?
Oh, wait.
What did you get?
You just fucked us, man.
Good.
What did you do?
Dude.
No way he got the thing.
Are you serious?
Welcome in, guys.
Welcome in.
It's over.
The game's over.
Welcome in, guys.
Very good.
Oh, shit.
Let's show that 85 coins.
Very good.
Oh, thank God.
He's spreading the wealth.
He's actually GG.
Yeah.
Bro, I don't want to play anymore.
I want to go back to my card simulator.
This is awesome.
Yay!
We're just sitting piggyback.
We've got nothing else going on in our lives.
Chiw and I, I'm glad I did that to you.
Spread the wealth!
Are we married?
Because you just took half my shit, man.
Spread the wealth!
And now, all of a sudden, your name is now ChillBingle.
You've taken the Bingle lineage.
Congratulations.
I don't want to be Bingle.
Dude, I lost everything now.
Lost everything.
Guys, we're now known as the Bingles.
Welcome in.
Congratulations.
Oh, my God.
Conrad.
What's the point, man?
What's the point?
Take my money again.
I didn't even want it.
There's no way.
There's actually no way.
Dude, this is the worst luck I've had in a Mario Party game.
This is so sad.
Oh, my God.
This is actually...
It's unwinnable.
It's unwinnable for me.
You got robbed 60 coins.
Oh, my God.
It's just...
It's so bad.
Sakuno had me coin.
How many coins did you originally have?
A hundred something.
He did like a hundred.
I lost, yeah, around 60 or something.
Oh, he lost even more than 60.
Something between like 60 to 70 coins.
Guys, I want to...
I want to...
He's in mourning, dude.
He's in mourning.
This is the voice he started when...
Before he crashed out.
So, there's a world.
There's a world.
Oh, my God.
We get it again.
Dude, this is the worst luck I've ever seen.
I mean, this is just...
Guys, I had 20 coins going in.
It's certified bullshit.
It's certified.
It is.
Call it out.
Let him know.
I'm going to let...
Are you going to be totally a copy of Mario Party?
A Mario Party covered in strawberries disc to teach it a lesson for giving me bad luck.
Chill, do you ever like take...
Do you ever take him on walks?
Like out?
Yeah, we do.
And I'll put him in like a little red...
Oh, that's so cute.
A red wagon.
And I'll pull him around in a red wagon.
That's so cute.
Oh, my God.
I will say, anything that's green, he'll eat.
So, my wife, she painted her nails green once.
And he went for the nails.
Oh, my God.
Wait, does your wife like your Barney voice?
That only rams...
No, she hates my Barney voice.
Objects.
No, wait.
I've seen that.
No, I've also seen that.
Have you guys seen that?
No.
Yeah.
Like this guy will put black tape on his shoe and it rams his shoe.
And it just attacks.
Yeah.
That's so cute.
It takes the tape off and it doesn't attack.
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Oh, that's not cute.
Never mind.
Now that you said that, it's not...
I didn't think of it like that.
The tortoise is a bear.
Yeah, tortoise.
Oh, my God.
What do you mean?
Wait.
Do you mean ram as in like it fucks it?
Or do you mean it...
What?
It attacks.
No.
It just rams it regularly.
It just headbutts it.
Like, you know, headbutts.
Wait.
Are you ever gonna get Tortolini a girlfriend?
Oh, my God.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Why not?
I think he's taking the path of like priesthood.
He's gonna be celibate, you know.
Why?
Is he gonna be alone forever?
You're good.
One year.
Same.
I gotta send you the picture.
I should.
I showed him two turtles humping on my phone and I showed him that and he was just staring at it like, what?
That is crazy.
What?
So he's gonna be like a hundred plus year old virgin because you won't give him a girlfriend?
Yeah.
But he's gonna turn into like Captain America.
Wasn't Captain America a hundred year old virgin and he got superpowers?
He did.
And maybe that's...
He's gonna be the Grand Wizard.
That's his secret.
That's Tortolini's origin story, dude.
That's how he gets juiced up.
Okay, guys.
Dude.
I'm against chilled.
He has no delay.
He's crazy, bro.
I'm lagging so bad.
I can't even play the game.
That's right.
Dude, they already have ten.
Okay.
When you guys on the top right, how many...
Do you have like the blue bars?
I have blue bars.
I have blue bars, too.
What do you guys have?
Okay.
You got blue bars.
I think I have bars.
You don't have...
I'm using Wi-Fi.
How do you not have...
You don't have any bars.
I have Wi-Fi.
I have four blue bars up there.
I have four, too.
I have blue bars.
It's next to your name.
It's in the corner.
Yeah.
Look bottom left now, next to your name.
But I also...
I got some blue bars.
Oh, it's because I'm hoaxed here.
But the delay for me is because of my capture card, not the...
Oh, wait.
You're playing via your capture card?
Yeah.
I'm playing through a capture card.
So there's like a full second of delay.
Yeah.
I play like...
I use like a...
Oh, yeah.
I mean, that's not even the problem, though.
The real problem is I just lost like 70 coins almost.
I don't think like the delay is really what got me.
I think the game, it just wasn't going to let me win no matter what.
But you can have multiple problems in life.
You know, like why just stop at one problem?
I got like four problems at the moment right now.
I mean, the delay sucks too.
But yeah, like those 70 coins, that's going to be hitting me harder, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, maybe the star will move closer to you now.
Maybe...
I didn't want it to.
I don't want to see how bad my luck is yet.
Guys, we have a common enemy and it's Doki.
No, no, no.
I'm just chilling.
Gang up on Elm.
Don't forget what he did to you.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't forget the common enemy.
Don't forget he was the one that triggered the Bowser that spread the wealth.
Guys, he's British.
So we're targeting the British.
He's British.
That's true.
Canadians and Americans got to work together against the British.
I'm the token British guy of the group.
You can't do that.
It's because you are the token British guy that we have to.
We're just you, but you know, like American version.
So it's the same.
Yeah, like better.
I'm an honorary American.
You know, I can totally...
If you're an honorary American, burn your British passport right now.
Okay.
Hang on.
If she gets a star, we just quit.
W aura type shit.
Okay.
I mean...
Free $10 for first place.
Yay!
Okay.
Let me...
Wait.
How close was the star to whoever that was in front of?
It's close.
It's very close to Doki.
She's going to get it.
This is upsetting.
It's pretty wild, man.
It's pretty wild.
Let me just buy that Chomko.
Let me just get that Chomko in advance.
Just in case.
I mean, we're still at turn 11, okay?
You want to peak at turn 24 because you have 14 turns of potential downfall.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
It's all about the end game, guys.
Guys, it's not about now, it's about the end game.
I'm just edging for 24 turns and then I'm gonna come around and I'm gonna score big at the end.
I don't know, I didn't mean it.
Can I show you the turn of the 20?
We're still on turn 11.
Oh my god!
I don't know if you can reduce the turns.
It's just funny because 25 doesn't even give you extra bonus stars.
20 gives you 2, 30 gives you 3.
So you've picked the middle which does absolutely nothing.
Wait, so we don't even have bonus stars?
We're just going straight in?
Can I try?
He's trying to rip the game.
We don't even add turns.
Add 30 just so we can have bonus stars.
We'll still get 2 bonus stars, we just won't get a third one.
Oh, we don't get a third.
Oh, okay.
38 to the star.
I need to go to the bathroom, I'll be right back.
Which means guys, when he's gone, we can now walk on our strategy.
Okay, I think he's gone now.
We're gonna keep going.
We're gonna keep going and then we gotta make it fast so we can get to the minigame.
Then we grief him, guys.
We grief him.
Wait, no, but he can't start the minigame.
We have...
This is free coinage, guys.
Oh, damn, you're right.
We do have minigame now.
Free coinage.
Okay, but what if we use the cursed dice on him and he doesn't even know?
You know, what if we...
Dude, you can steal stars from him.
You can steal money from him.
You can steal anything from him right now.
I can steal a little bit of cash.
I can steal some cash.
Just a little bit.
Just a little bit of cash.
But I need to be nighttime.
You guys gotta make it nighttime for me because I can't still turn the day.
Don't worry.
I'll make it nighttime for you.
Just for you.
Oh, wait.
Hey, guys.
Lucky Space.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can make it happen.
Lucky Space.
You get chomp call.
And then like...
Oh, yeah.
$15, you dudes.
$15 is pretty good.
This is almost as good luck as Transformers.
Good luck.
God, I love Transformers.
Me too.
Dude, I watched the last Transformers film on the plane with the gorilla and I was so confused.
The gorilla?
Oh, Beast Wars?
I thought that was just dog shit.
Dude, I was so confused.
I was like, why is King Kong robotic?
Because I thought you were talking about the newest one with Transformers 1.
Yeah.
Transformers 1.
I thought that was pretty good.
That one was really good.
Yeah.
How do we do this one?
Are you a Transformers fan, Doki?
Yeah.
You even read the comics too.
Oh, nice.
But like...
Yeah.
You're not into...
You're into Transformers.
You're not into Transformers, right?
What does that...
What do you mean?
It's like you want to...
Like I mean, you don't...
You're trying to...
Wait.
You're trying to fuck a Transformer?
I would never fuck a Transformer.
Wait.
Unless, of course, the Transformer wants to fuck me.
But I'm just saying.
I...
Oh, so you're cool with that.
You're cool with that.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm just...
I mean, I'm very...
Like, if you're cool with that, like, you know, I won't judge you.
You know?
I won't judge you for it.
Bro, I love Lola Bunny.
I'll say it.
I'll say it's great to be in my space.
Yeah, but that's not a robot.
I had a friend called Rain...
Oh, wait.
You know Rain Doki.
She is in a complete obsession with trying to sleep with Garfield the cat.
I don't think that she should.
I think that's bestiality.
I think that's against the rules.
I think that's...
Yeah, I think that's against, like, any law.
She did...
She did the most fuckable cartoon characters.
Her number one instinct was Garfield.
Oh, no.
Her instinct was Garfield.
Does she own a cat?
Dude, I...
Die...
Dude.
I invited her to my coffee...
All right, Doki.
So, you know, let's judge the people, Doki.
Which transformers?
Transformers, Doki.
Oh.
I think Starscream is my favorite.
Yeah, okay.
Wait.
Can I bring up a list of transformers?
Transformers...
You don't even know the transfor...
Are you a Decepticon or an Autobot?
I'm a Decepticon.
I'm a Mark Wahlberg, whatever he was.
Mark...
Oh, so you're a movies Transformers fan?
I kind of am.
I'm a...
You're not even a real Transformers fan!
You're Michael Bayer!
I will say there was a toy I had that I really miss.
I was not going to give you Bumble Deez Nuts.
I was not going to give it to you.
I was going to take you and ignore and continue on with my Transformers Beast Wars talk where I had a Tyrannosaurus Rex.
Oh, it's from Burger King or McDonald's?
I think it's from like KB Toys or something.
Oh, I thought you meant like the... you know how like there was like those like Transformers...
Oh, wait, he's back.
Okay.
Oh, no, I was not looking.
No, okay.
I was definitely...
Oh, I don't know.
No, I'm fucked.
I don't know.
I was not looking at the x-rays.
I'm just gonna keep opening.
Wait, I don't understand.
What do you mean?
It's like Burger King.
I'm not looking at the boxes.
The TSA griefed me last time I went to America.
They fucking suck.
Dude, they always give me the extra pat down every single time.
They pulled me into a separate room.
I had to... I got like interrogated.
It was horrible.
What did you do?
I didn't do anything.
I was just me.
Oh, yeah, honestly.
I just said hello.
They're like, get this kid.
Fucking frisk this guy now.
Dude, when I went to Comic Con, I brought my Yu-Gi-Oh!
Dex with me.
And I guess the way they show up on the scanner, they look like just like weird things bunched together.
So the guy's taking my Yu-Gi-Oh!
Dex out of my backpack, thumbing through my cards.
And I got some expensive cards in there.
And like my ass is clenching.
Oh, dude.
I was gonna mouth off to the TSA, but then you see that sign mouthing off at seven years in prison.
I'm like, ah, come on!
Wait, what?
Is that true?
You should have done it.
You can't say anything to them.
You say anything to them, you're fucking, you're missing your flight and you're getting in trouble.
You should have said you had a knife.
Did you know?
Just say you're going to London.
They'll understand.
Oh, my God.
Hey, another chomp call.
Let's go.
But then like, see, see, they'd be like, oh, my God, you have a knife.
And they'd forget about your cards.
They dropped my Yu-Gi-Oh!
cards.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
They won't damage the Yu-Gi-Oh!
cards.
Yeah, yeah.
They'll be looking for your knife, not your cards.
Yeah.
And then you'll be like, sorry, I didn't mean to say knife.
That was just a typo in my brain.
Dude, how does Doki have four stars and I have zero?
This is wealth inequality.
It's about turn 20.
What are we, in Los Angeles or something?
It's about turn 20, Sekuro.
Turn 20 will be okay.
Jeffrey Bezos.
This is crazy, I tells ya.
I'm going to start my Amazon warehouse soon.
Oh, my God.
I am not pissing in the bottle.
I am not working for you.
Hey, look, it's close.
It's close to LM.
No, it's close to child.
Yeah, it's close to child.
We can finally get one.
I'm back.
What happened?
What I missed?
What did I grab?
What did I miss?
I'm going to be on the board soon, don't you worry.
Wait, I'm the way.
Wait, Doki.
Doki, my duo, we can't let this happen, surely.
Surely.
Oh, sorry, but like...
Okay, let's see.
I'm an ally.
I pre-game Woman's Month early.
It's in March.
I've been pre-gaming since April.
You've been pre-gaming?
Yeah, I'm pre-gaming.
Always with positive comments like, Doki, you're looking lovely today.
See, I'm pre-gaming Woman's Month.
I'm doing my part.
So, like, you wouldn't have just done that normally?
Oh, wait, yeah, you know what I've done that normally?
It was ex-opposite.
Wait a minute, he's only saying that for Woman's Month.
Yeah!
Oh, my God!
Wait a minute.
Is Chill the bad person in general?
I'm an ally.
Chill hates women confirmed, guys.
You heard it.
Yeah, Chill hates women.
Call him The Word.
There's a sound clip of Chill.
He's misogynistic.
He's misogynistic, you sicko.
Oh, that's a fucking joke.
Oh, my God!
I guess Chill's not getting that.
That's for being a woman-hater.
That's for the women out there, guys.
That's for the women out there.
I've only pushed a couple of ladies in my life and only kicked one child.
That's for sounding like Barney every time you try and talk to them.
I love you.
That's for having a sexy voice, you sick fuck.
Dude, who's even near this thing?
Wait, Ellen's near.
Yeah, he just needs ten.
I'm doing...
I'm doing this for women everywhere.
For women?
Shit.
As a woman,
you shouldn't buy that so I can buy it.
That's why I only got a nine.
I did that for you, dude.
Ellen, leave one for me, man.
Just one star for me.
Oh, yeah.
It doesn't matter.
We just fired you.
Let me grab this chunk real quick.
Like, I would just chuck.
It would.
You guys are such gatekeepers.
You are going to hell.
I'm going through the gate and they're just pulling up the ladder behind you with these goddamn...
Wait, women?
You're saying women are gatekeepers?
What are you trying to say right now?
What are you trying to say?
Every single time.
To a woman and a British guy.
You are breaking barriers, woman.
Pull the ladder up.
What are you trying to say?
To a woman and a British guy that we're gatekeepers.
That's crazy.
What are you trying to say?
Definitely to the British guy.
The British guy, yeah.
Yeah, I was going to say.
Oh, you're right.
Sorry.
You're right.
No, no.
You got that there.
Yeah, we need to gatekeep the British out of here.
I'm going through this gate.
I'm in Hala, I remember.
I'm in Hala.
Oh my god.
Come on in.
Custom item bag.
Item bag.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Get chomka.
Get another chomka.
Here we go.
Dang it.
10 coins?
We're getting that wealth back, man.
We're getting that wealth back.
Yeah, get that.
Go get rich.
I need generational wealth so my pet penguin can survive.
Are you allowed to get a pet hyrax?
What the fuck is a hyrax?
Sounds like a hyrax.
Dude, hyraxes are all the rage.
They're the coolest new animal on the block.
What are they?
A hyrax?
They're crazy looking, dude.
Let me send you a picture.
Oh, he showed me this before.
They actually do look good.
Is this a new animal?
They're not new.
Did you know they're related to elephants?
No.
A hyrax?
I want to be honest.
I thought he was going to...
When he said elephant, I was like, this motherfucker says me.
I'm going to kill him.
What the fuck is that?
Dude, look at how mischievous they look, dude.
These are the greatest.
They're cute as hell.
Oh my god.
That thing is so cute.
He doesn't pay his taxes.
Look at that.
That thing is on the run from the IRS for sure.
It's on the run from the IRS 100%.
I'm putting this back in the game, okay?
I'm going to try and get the full-on swap for us, man.
I'm pretty sure you can't...
Wait, are they...
If they're not endangered, I'm pretty sure you can technically own it.
It's just like, you know, morality's sake, you know?
Morality's sake, you shouldn't own Exile.
You got to be Doki or Elem on life and life.
And chill.
Remember all the times we played games together?
Were you?
There's no point trading anything with me.
Nothing's really going to change, you know?
I got to focus.
That's a 30-point...
This is what it had.
Shields in a choke.
He's in a choke.
Trust me.
They call him choke chaos.
Choke chaos.
Here we go.
Darswap 20 double swap.
Choke chaos.
Darswap 20 double star.
Yes!
No.
We're defending.
We're taking one.
Oh no.
No.
We're two.
Okay, I hope he chooses me.
Because I'm gonna pick...
Oh!
Oh my.
Wow.
And that just takes the entire game away from me.
Choke.
This is what happens when you...
The whole game.
Oh my gosh.
This changes everything.
Oh, it feels so good.
It feels so good, Elem.
It feels so good.
Everything I grind is full.
Hey, can we get a Bowser Revolution?
Can we get a Bowser Revolution?
Oh my god!
I want you to know, Chilled, I'm gonna go out of my way to get 150 coins and steal everything from you.
You gotta get to the right area and land right there.
I will do everything in my power to make sure you don't win.
I just want to lay out a blueprint for you.
Wait, how do I do this?
It's your turn, Sykkuno.
Your turn to steal from someone else.
This is my shot I've never lost.
Anything you give to Sykkuno, I will also steal from him.
No!
Oh shit.
Oh, you guys are trying so hard!
Look at you guys go!
This is a 10 years of fucking...
10 years of biopart right there!
Wait, but if I win, Elm gets money!
Think about the greater good!
Yes!
10 years of biopart probably doesn't help you.
Hey, at least we lived, you know?
They picked us up.
At least you have, like, you know, Elm stars.
You're almost as bad of a spot as Elm.
You just made me beat the shit out of my chair and now the Elm's hanging off.
Hey, second place has never felt so good.
Okay?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yeah, it is.
It's looking real grim out here.
Oh god.
No way you're chomp calling right now.
This is...
Diabololica.
What?
The only one who's closest to it was...
You're not even close to that star, Saikudo!
I don't know.
I'm tilted and lashing out at anybody.
You're fighting for the people now.
You're here for the people.
Saik, me and you, we're the same right now.
So maybe we should unite as a duo.
You know?
Hear me out.
Alright, give me half your money and we'll call it a deal.
Give me half of your money and then invest in me early.
You know?
You should invest... the US stock market's better.
Yeah.
That's true.
We're doing pretty good right now, I think.
No, but the British pound is still higher than the US currency.
Yeah, but that's because it's backed by the monarchy.
It doesn't really count.
That's true.
Alright, guys.
Did you crash the game?
Did you crash?
I didn't.
No.
He mauled it and crashed the game.
He fucking did!
He crashed the game!
No, Saik disconnected.
Saik disconnected.
You disconnected!
Yeah, we can get you back in.
We can reset.
Dude, you crashed us so hard.
Oh my god!
What's happening?
Yeah, he could just rejoin.
Yeah, you just have to re-invite him.
No, I think you just straight up join.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's fine.
You can do the moves while we wait for him.
I'm gonna steam my voice real quick while we wait.
We gotta watch this dice roll while you steam this voice.
Oh my god.
We're all getting dizzy staring at this.
Let me hear you one of those.
I still can't believe you actually got the swap.
That's actually fucking crazy.
You honestly chilled?
Yeah, that was an insane swap.
You think I'm done?
I'm going up even more.
Whoa!
He's mad with power!
Can I go this way?
I was your fan.
I was your fan and I still am.
Chilled, come on.
You're such a fan.
When did the creatures kick me out?
When was it?
I would not remember that because that was a dark time for all of us.
So I choose not to remember that.
Yeah, I locked that out.
That's a true fan.
Okay, but...
I'm rejoining.
It says rejoining, please wait there.
Oh, we have some bad news for you.
Your character just landed on Bowser.
Yeah, you got a thousand coins, Sykkuno!
Dude, dude, I'm telling you the NPC always gets me, bro.
No, actually this is pretty good because you can actually go and do the stealing.
Yeah, you're close to the swap.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're literally at the swap area.
You need to get a four for swap.
Maybe we can curse you.
It should reconnect after the minigame.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It has to play through one, which is stupid.
Nintendo almost got the online right.
They were close.
I don't think they ever will.
I'm hoping...
Maybe the Switch 2?
You know, maybe?
Elem, in case...
I mean, you were asking for it.
The stores have been, you said, juiced up?
Is that what the terminology you're using?
Wait, what does that mean?
I don't know, he said it earlier.
Like, they got better stuff now.
They got different stuff.
Oh yeah, because it's like halfway point.
Yeah.
Oh, because we're still doing minigame now.
You're about to do the minigame.
You should be good after this.
You're the 1v3.
You're the one.
You got this.
Just look away.
There's no way you can lose.
Yeah, there's no way NPC you could lose, Sakuno.
Wait, am I...
Do I just have to wait till the next game, I guess?
Yeah, I think so.
Okay, okay, that's fine.
I'll chill here.
Wait, what if Rosalina never readies up?
Wait...
No, I think we need...
No, we need Elem to readies, so then it would...
...
Yeah, we just need...
Give Elem a British ping.
It might take like 2 minutes before he hears our pleas.
Elem, please.
Elem!
Elem, he's not even deafened.
He's just steaming his voice out of the room.
Elem!
Elem, please.
Can't believe I got Donalewald by Elem.
He's not even there to appreciate it, too.
He'll never know.
So what's he doing?
He's just huffing vapor right now?
Like, is that what he's doing?
So, yeah.
Yeah, that's how you fix your throat.
It's just steam.
Oh, well good.
At least he's being healthy.
Wait, if I fuck up, do we all fuck up?
No, no, no, no, no.
We all get one fuck up.
We're all entitled to one fuck up.
Oh, okay.
So that's good.
So I can fuck up for all of a sudden, but it won't matter.
Does anyone know where Elem lives?
Can somebody go over there right now?
He's from the UK, I think.
Brethren, sorry, I'm back, I'm back, I'm back.
Wow.
You sound worse.
What happened?
I was just steaming my voice.
How do you sound worse?
Yeah.
Wait, what did I go?
Oh, I did it right.
We're all good, we're all good.
We get a point.
I'm going left, I'm going left.
I'm going up.
I got it, I got it.
Oh!
Yes.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
We're winning.
You're also part of our team.
Yeah, you're a part of my team.
I'm so glad I can see everything that's happening.
Where are you going?
No, they got me.
How's my bot doing?
He's out of the wire.
Yeah, yeah, we won!
We did it!
We lost or we won?
We won!
Dude, the AI always throws it, I swear.
It always throws it.
Alright, you should be back now.
Yay, we're joining.
Oh, here he comes, here he comes.
Oh, okay, it's joining, it's joining.
It's time.
Oh my god, we still have...
We're only halfway there.
Oh, there we go.
He's just waiting.
He's just connecting.
Yeah, I like the little drum beat that they got.
When they said drum roll, I didn't know how long they were gonna go for.
It's like the...
The Simpsons intro with the couch gag.
They just play the same three notes over and over again until the gag is over.
Why did I do 25 turns, dude?
What's wrong with me?
I don't know, you went...
That was a lot of turns.
It said 75...
It said 75 minutes.
I was like, oh, that'll be fine.
No, no, the estimate time is always less than what it actually is.
Wait, really?
Oh, hey, they gave me another chop call!
They know!
They know it's my favorite!
Why?
Okay, surely, surely...
Big roll, big roll.
Not a six, dude.
That's pretty... pretty big.
What am I gonna buy?
What do they have?
The custom dice block so you can go back to chance time and hurt us.
Oh, there's a warp block!
The custom dice block would be the best strat.
Why?
It's open.
When you got zero dollars, yeah, you gotta go and try and swap your money with someone else.
I'm gonna take more than their money.
I'm coming for everything.
Everything.
You know, I'm gonna stop getting stars now because, like, it's not worth it.
It really is.
You can buy a hundred and fifty to steal two stars.
It's just not worth it.
Go chance time.
Oh, you didn't get it.
You had to get four.
Oh, but you can steal stars.
You can steal cash.
Yeah, for free.
Like, forty-five dollars for free?
I mean, with ten more turns, like, there's so much time.
There's actually a glitch.
The more you press A, the less money you get.
Even when I spam this, it doesn't do anything.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't, yeah.
I just wouldn't push it for science.
I'm gonna go halfway.
I feel like that's accountable.
Just don't push it and see what happens, you know?
Dude, I still lose fourteen coins.
Did you guys go all the way?
I went halfway.
I went halfway as well.
Okay.
I was not reading it.
I didn't realize I had to mash.
I was like, what are they talking about?
I was like, oh, I'm supposed to mash.
Dude, no way I'm on the Bowser spot.
Wait, are you on the Bowser spot?
Revolution!
Dude, I needed those coins.
You got sixty-seven coins back.
That's what they took from you last time.
Yeah!
You got paid.
You got your tax returns.
This is why you should do your taxes.
You can get your tax returns.
You need double dice.
You might be able to.
I just need a seventeen.
It's so doable.
It's so believable!
Holy dude, it's so doable.
I mean, that ten was good.
That was brutal.
That would have been...
What do you mean?
You're coming in to ruin my life points, man.
I would never do such a thing.
You should buy that triple dice, though, that maybe you could have caught the star.
I don't want to hear her anymore.
Hey, look, you bought the triple dice!
It's huge!
Do I just go this way?
Yeah, fuck it.
You're not even going to get the star?
No, I'm not going to give you the satisfaction.
Then I don't need to use my chop calls.
At least I don't have to waste it.
I have a plan.
I don't understand.
It makes so much sense.
I can see it.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, I'm never going to get to a star as long as I can't chop sixes.
There's like three chop calls out there.
Why is it always against me, dude?
Why is it against me?
You know, you should have just went for the star, so I would have used the chop call.
You got a massive advantage on river raiders.
It's so good for the one.
Yeah, but how does it work?
What do I do?
You gotta take us away from the coins.
I just gotta drag you away from...
But I'm so slow.
Like, how do I speed up?
You don't.
You bought the more expensive shell.
I don't know.
You should have just invested on a better boat.
What model of shell is this, dude?
This thing is slow as heck.
I can't even see Rosalina's shell.
It's just hilarious.
I've never realized it before.
Wait, what if I run you guys into the tree?
Yeah, that's why.
Oh, thanks, dude.
Thanks.
Can you guys stop dragging me, please?
You're being really cringe.
Thank you so much.
We're not even dragging you!
You're controlling the boat!
Yeah, the cringe is in now.
It's mine.
Oh, that's cringe.
Yeah, thank you.
Oh, you did it for us!
That's so sweet.
Why did I have my friends, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, because we're the homies, you know?
That's what I'm saying, that's what I'm saying.
Okay, here we go.
You have now officially hit the 155 mark.
If you get the key and the custom dice block, you're in a good position to steal a lot of stars.
Not that you would ever take from us, because we're friends here.
I would get two stars, because it's not worth it yet.
Yeah.
You should buy a star.
You should buy one.
Think about it.
That would be so funny.
But I want you to know, Childe, I'm coming back for the stars you stole from me.
You're gonna take two from me?
I'm gonna leave you with nothing.
Whoa!
Nothing?
That's exactly what I started with.
I'm gonna leave you with nothing.
He's gonna go back to where he started.
Oh, hey!
This is what you needed, Childe.
Oh, come on, world!
16.
Oh, I'm just 16.
Hey!
Microwave my juice.
I'll be back.
I'm sick.
I need microwave juice to clear my throat.
Microwave juice?
Microwave and lemonade mixed with apple juice.
Custom Dice Block is probably big right here.
That sounds kinda good.
I can't even lie.
Nah, I'm gonna get a Warp Lock.
I think it's fun here.
Dude, apple juice and lemonade sounds like it would be kinda crazy.
Dude, I'll use some microwave apple sauce and eat it by the bowl.
What?
By itself?
Yeah, dude, apple sauce by itself goes crazy.
Yeah, warm apple sauce is real good.
Why don't you put anything on it?
You don't have to.
Because I'm British, we don't do seasoning.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, they don't do good flavor.
That's true.
Dude, when people say seasoning, I'm just adding salt and pepper.
That's all I'm adding.
You should try the Everything Bagel Salt.
It's really good.
You can put it on anything, like your avocado, your egg.
Doesn't everything bagel salt?
Yeah, so it's like a seasoning, but it's like everything but the bagel.
So it's like poppy seeds, sesame seeds, salt.
That sounds good.
It does sound good.
It's really good.
You throw it on some avocado or some eggs and you just elevate your sandwich.
Dude, I wish bagels were a thing in the UK.
They're just not.
We just don't have bagels.
Well, we have bagels, but they're just like...
Okay, I will eat bagels just by themselves.
Oh, that's fair.
Just a raw bagel.
You know?
A humble, raw bagel.
Do you mean plain or raw?
You know, you don't put any like...
Oh hey, I got another one.
I can buy a triple dice too.
I shouldn't judge because I call them blank tortillas.
So it's fine.
When I was in LA, whenever I had this thing, I would just eat plain bread in bed.
So I'm known as a crumb cuddler.
Are you okay?
I feel like the more we learn about your eating habits, the more...
You're not okay.
I don't think he is.
You're just like really hungry.
I'll go grab plain pieces of bread, but the bad thing about it is I'll just...
I'll be sat in darkness just eating these slices of bread.
In darkness?
You don't even turn on the light?
I'll just eat them, but then I'll eat them right...
I'm like, okay, that's a little snack.
I'll do that.
Then I'll forget that I've eaten them.
So there'll be crumbs on my chest.
I'll roll over and just roll around in the crumbs.
I've had it where we had a...
Oh my god.
Okay.
We were in Malibu like seven, eight years ago when I was with Sea Nanners, Vanos, Syndicate, and...
Syndicate and Vanos, I think they went to the Kings game.
So me and Adam, we made dinner.
We made like a huge pot of pasta for everybody.
A penne alla vodka for when they come back.
They didn't get back until two o'clock in the morning.
But what happened was two o'clock in the morning, I'm sitting there in the fridge just eating pasta with my hand.
I was caught.
The Syndicate walks in vlogging.
I don't think it ever made it to the video, but it was just the most embarrassing thing ever.
You're just sitting there.
Fist in penne alla vodka.
Just out of the fridge.
Oh my god.
So I'm with you, Elem.
I'm with you, man.
Do you have the deleted scene?
Do we have the clip?
No, no.
I don't think it ever made it to the VOD.
Thank Christ.
Wait, so who was vlogging it?
Syndicate was.
Okay, alright.
What's this, Twitter?
This was in 2016.
My god, I was fist deep in that box.
Oh my god.
I don't need any more coins.
Oh no.
Oh, you know, we could get a little chance time again.
Oh.
Why not?
Doki, you're so wealthy.
I should see if we can give something to somebody else.
No, that's okay.
We're all pretty rich right now.
We count again because I can't count.
Yeah, but like, Women's Month is coming up, you know?
I'm free baby.
Do you forget Chubb hates women?
Oh shit, you're right.
I forgot.
Never mind.
Will it for my friend, Shubble?
Don't push me, Chubb!
And I never pushed her though.
That's what they all say.
Don't push me, Chubb.
Oh god, good times.
Top ranked woman hater since 2008.
Dude, at least I'm on some leaderboards, okay man?
Oh my god.
What, you're winning this?
Oh wait, you're not winning this either.
Oh, this is a spicy meatball.
Oh.
Dude, just swap me with Doki.
Do it for the people.
If you don't do it for Sakuno, then you're not a homie.
Swap me with Doki.
Oh man.
Guys, come on.
Will you do it to me?
You're gonna do this to me?
Your biggest fan?
Star 20.
Big swap, okay?
Star 20, big swap.
Why don't you gamble?
Close your eyes and just hit A.
Just let fate play.
Dude, what if you...
I'm so relaxed.
Well at that point, it doesn't really matter.
Now I get three coins!
I'm supposed to use an ally, guys.
See?
Oh no.
She was dropping the rankings right now.
He's dropping in the rankings.
No, he got kicked out of the leaderboards.
Is this a double coin bonus mini game?
Oh, yeah.
Here we go.
Oh, crazy cutters.
Oh god.
With latency, this one's just real bad.
Oh, dude.
There's actually no way.
There's just straight up no way I can do this.
Dude, I'm...
My hands shake.
It moves while...
Oh, no, it moves without touching it.
Dude, this one's so bad with the lag.
I'm gonna try it.
This is pretty weird with the...
This is a $20 reduce, man.
Here we go, here we go.
You're going reverse in them?
Oh, wait, there's a...
Holy Christ.
Dude, this is so...
Oh my god.
I'm drilling, I'm drilling.
Dude, I've horribly messed this up.
I've...
Dude, the delay though.
The delay, am I right?
Guys, I've done so bad.
I'm gonna look at the moment it's done.
Oh, dude.
I can't even... I can't see.
Wait, that looks pretty good.
Where are you going?
What happened?
My jackhammer was so slow.
Sykkuno gave it a hairline.
It was so slow, I just tried to close it.
I was like, okay, there's three seconds left.
I'm gonna try and close it before it's too late.
He just gave up.
I gave it a hairline.
That's crazy.
Holy shit.
I got no coins for that, what the fuck?
Dude, that happens when you suck, dude.
Damn.
Sorry, I'm being so reliant.
I'm so sorry.
Holy shit.
I'm looking for the lucky you.
Lucky you.
There it is.
Walk it down.
I'm gonna get some stars eventually.
Yeah, you can get the swap, you know?
I don't think I can get this.
Come on, low numbers, low numbers, Jesus, thank you.
No!
Tell him you know what to call.
Oh, it's time.
It's time.
Finally, we get to be the dicks.
Finally.
Yes.
Oh, you're gonna call it?
Wait.
Oh.
Let me see.
If you call it, if you call it, Sykkuno would not get that star.
Are you really gonna do that to him?
Am I in the way?
You're close, you're like 12.
Are you really gonna do it to him?
Damn.
Oh.
You're really gonna call it so he can't get it?
You would.
I mean, Doki, I mean, you think I would do that to Sykkuno?
There's no way.
That is so fucked.
Alright, let's test your friendship right now.
I'm gonna test your friendship right now.
Damn, are you really?
Respect, I think, question mark.
I don't know.
Lucky.
Okay, okay.
What do I get?
Oh, 12 points!
Let's go!
Yeah, we're on turn 16.
We have a long way to go.
We have!
How far is this?
Wait, what?
Another hour?
Oh, jeez, Rick.
Dude, it's been two hours for 16 turns.
A one.
Big numbers, big numbers.
There's no way.
Hey, look, Ellen didn't call in the warp.
That's a good friend right there.
Well, you can't even wait.
You can't even reach it anyway.
I'm gonna reach it next turn.
Oh, oh yeah.
Here we go.
I'm in last place.
Yeah, exactly.
That would be so fucked if you do that to him.
Exactly.
You wouldn't even get anything.
I never would, I never would.
You'll gain nothing.
There's zero reason to do it.
Zero.
He's gonna do it.
He's gonna do it next turn.
He's gonna make you so close to the...
And it goes near Doki and she gets a sixth star.
Yeah, you wouldn't wanna do that to him.
But I also wouldn't wanna do that for you, Doki.
I'm getting penalized.
Yeah, but then he's the one that's supposed to...
You want your friend to get the star, don't you?
I mean, of course.
Okay, we gotta make sure Chill doesn't win every minigame where he's gonna get a star.
A bonus star.
We gotta spread the wins there.
Guys, I'm doing my best here.
Oh wow, that was a double kill.
How do you win?
You just have to jump over.
You have to jump over, you have to time it.
You just have to time it.
Yeah, you'll be fine.
Just wait for me to do my jump and then you jump over my jump.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
See, that's the example.
We lock in.
No!
I have the one true gamer left.
It's up to you.
We can't have him win all of it.
Dude, it's GG, bro.
What is this?
Why are you making fun of me?
You died way earlier.
He's spamming.
He's literally spamming.
I bet he's using a Switch Pro controller too.
Why am I gonna change?
You're not blocking, man.
He's a Mario guy, dude.
I bet he has a Switch Pro controller as well.
I bet you.
100%.
I'm using the Joy-Cons on the Switch.
I'm using the Pro controller.
I knew it!
I knew he's got the Pro controller.
Exactly.
It had to be the Pro controller.
He's got the dongle.
He's got the Pro controller.
He's got everything.
Oh my god.
What happened?
That's insane.
That's actually OP.
How does Doki have this kind of luck?
Take the eyeball.
Maybe he'll accidentally click yes here.
You don't wanna do that, do you?
Guys, this is now Operation Chance Time.
It's the only way us men can get in.
Boys, we gotta stay together now.
We've gotta unite.
We've got to unite.
And if there's one thing men do, it's they definitely don't falter.
They definitely unite and don't hurt each other.
Never would.
Because Boys Night has never come crashing down before.
You guys, I'm having a great time.
Like, with all my friends, guys.
I fucking bet with six stars.
Six stars?
I got zero.
You guys, I'm having a great night on Boys Night, guys.
The rest of the entire game only has two.
I am in fourth place with less coins than you, you little shit.
Oh no, the Boys Night is ending again.
The boys are fighting.
See, that was so quick.
Dropshipping off Alibaba.
We called you a fucking dropshipper.
Oh my god.
You gotta get your money up, man.
Surely.
A humble four, I'll take that.
And then with my skeleton key.
Let's open the door.
Oh, he's gonna open the door.
He's gonna do the shuffle.
It's time.
Get me in there.
I'll miss the way the inside of your pocket feels, Elm.
That's what he actually said.
It's a real quote.
That's a real quote?
Oh wait, we could have revolution.
Yeah, another revolution.
If we get Bowser revolution, we may as well quit the game now.
Just don't get Bowser revolution.
This is all he has, Elm.
This is literally all he has.
Literally nothing else matters, but if you get Bowser revolution, we just give up.
I'm not gonna get Bowser revolution.
Watch this.
I'm just not gonna get it.
I'm not gonna get it, guys.
That's good.
You saved us.
You saved all of us.
You couldn't give half your coins to Bowser.
It could have been worse.
I'm not gonna save any of you, fuckers.
Don't be an ally.
Yeah!
Dude, voice chat's already done.
That lasted like...
I just got the key.
Is that the bank?
No, I think it's one past the bank.
Yeah.
You joined at night.
This is good.
If you go at night time, this is amazing.
I need you to make it night.
I think I'm right past it.
I mean, we'll see here.
Yeah, I'm just on the blue.
You have a key, though.
You can get in there.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, to be fair, there's still a lot of turns left, so anything could happen at this point.
Elm still doesn't have a star, so a triple steal just makes no sense.
You're right.
You're paying 150 for two stars.
That's expensive.
Yeah, I may as well do a double regular steal.
The worst item on the board?
Okay, game.
Well, that was a gripping turn.
Here we go.
Let's go!
Here we go!
I mean, hey!
All I'm saying is that Chilled won the last 1v3, so there's a chance.
There's a chance for you, Elm.
Follow my blueprint.
It definitely depends.
Oh, this is so winnable.
This one's definitely winnable.
Guys, guys, let's not follow each other, guys.
What do you mean?
You guys smell nice.
Guys, please.
We all have to be separated.
Guys!
Guys, trust me.
I've already won this.
Really?
Because I pulled up Sykkuno's stream right now.
I don't even think that helps.
I don't even know where I'm hiding.
Well, I know Sykkuno is behind the big mushroom.
Watch this.
I'm going behind the big mushroom.
I'm going behind the big mushroom, too.
I know he likes the big mushroom.
Done.
Can we go there?
Did you see me?
There's no way.
You could've gotten two of us behind that bush.
Guys, let's just stay.
I'll go A.
He can't close off.
He'll split up.
I'll go A.
Are you sure?
Yeah, I'll go A, too.
I'm just button mashing and I don't even know where I am.
No, you're actually going A.
You're actually going A.
What the fuck?
That is...
You guys, what?
What do you mean you guys?
Sykkuno, you were there with us.
What was that?
You were there with us.
You can't say you guys.
That was the biggest throw I've ever seen.
That was actually the biggest throw I've ever seen.
I didn't think you were going to be A, too.
All the time I've played Mario Party, I've never seen that in my life.
I think we suck.
Actually, the first time I've ever seen this occur.
It's triple kill.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe we were all at A.
What were we doing?
Wait, are you getting another one?
No, I'm not.
No, I'm not close to it.
I'll be honest, though.
I didn't even, like, know.
I was going A.
I was just mashing.
I was mashing.
And you know what?
I'm glad we all shared that experience together.
Yeah, I didn't know either.
I was literally mashing, too.
I'm glad we all shared that, too.
I pressed Y, but I went to A.
I don't know how this game works.
Okay.
You have to call it to stop her in her reign of terror.
But I'm an ally.
Yeah, but you were an ally for a long time.
So, like, it's fine.
But I'm an ally.
I want you to know Chill made me do this.
Chill made me do this.
Chill wants to go back on the leaderboard.
He literally forced my hand.
He's DMing me horrible slurs right now.
He's horrible.
Just Italian slurs.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Yeah, it's fine.
Here we go.
Oh, mamma mia!
Wait, it's right in front of him!
Elm, you're such an ally.
And when I get this event space, and then steal everything from Doki, it's gonna be great.
You're past it.
Dang it.
Hey, you got $4!
If you get Bowser Revolution, man, I'm all of that for you.
But I got all of the money.
He got 12 coins.
He didn't get Bowser Revolution.
All of me and your money.
Thank you so much.
The 12 coins will be so good.
Oh, wait!
Chill can get a star because he has a triple dice.
Finally.
The gods shine upon me.
No!
Roll low, roll low.
Big!
Wait, no, that's bad, right?
Oh, you're gonna risk it?
Let me look at the board.
Does this land me on...
It lands you on Bowser.
You need to risk it, man.
You gotta do it.
It's worth it.
You have zero stars at this point.
Why am I risking this?
It makes no sense.
It makes complete sense to do it.
You get 40 coins from the stealing.
It literally makes zero sense to do it.
As long as you don't get the revolution, you'll be fine.
This is potentially the stupidest decision I could make in this situation.
No!
You're gonna steal 40 coins next turn.
And you have a chance time attempt.
There's no way you're gonna ever get a revolution.
There's no way.
This is probably the worst financial decision of my Mario Party.
career.
There's no way your luck is that bad.
There's no way.
Lock it in, lock it down.
Dude, dude, it's insane.
I'm out there pouring.
This is insane.
The game doesn't want me to play it.
It just doesn't want me to play the game.
It doesn't...
It doesn't make sense.
The game doesn't make sense.
Spread the wealth!
Doki's going for 20 coins like 100.
How does Doki have 6 stars and 100 coins?
But we all have 100 coins, guys.
We're all equal.
I want you to notice, like, you didn't only fuck yourself, you fucked me as well.
Thank you so much.
Dude, she could buy 5 more stars.
It just doesn't...
The game is insane.
This is actually insane.
I just lost, like, 75 points.
After losing...
I've lost over 150 coins in this game alone.
Oh my god.
Like, I've lost more coins than most people make in a game.
That's crazy.
It's not even...
I pay more taxes than you've made.
Oh my god.
I've lost over 150 coins in this game alone, man.
What the fuck is this?
I went from first place to lost in, like, the whole time now.
Nothing has been going back.
Hey, hey, I got you, man.
I'm gonna turn the light on until the next round.
It doesn't matter.
He doesn't have 150 coins!
I'm trying to be an ally.
You're rubbing salt on the wound!
Yeah, but you get 40 coins!
I've only got one option left.
This is crazy.
This is actually crazy.
You can't believe you're rubbing salt on his wound by making it nighttime.
Boys, it's chance time, okay?
It's chance time.
The only thing we can do now is buy custom dice blocks and pray for chance times.
That's all we can do.
That's all we can do at this point.
This luck is just shockingly bad.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
We have so many turns left.
I could lose the six stars so quickly.
I don't even need turns.
It's over.
Hey, I felt that way when I had zero stars once.
It made me feel better.
Yeah, and I feel like shit still.
So, like, there's a chance.
Oh, man.
Okay, here we go.
Lock it in, lock it down.
Yes.
This is great.
Don't be tug of war.
We did so many 1v... I feel like every minigame has been 1v3.
I think so far, honestly, I think... Oh, wait.
I love this one, though.
I'm goaded.
Dude, I'm actually goaded this one.
I'm running right towards it.
Wait, this is hard.
Wait, this is so hard.
I'm too good.
What?
Oh, good work, you two.
Look at that.
This is not fair.
Why do I get this one?
It's a simple dub.
This is not fair.
They hate the rich.
Oh, went straight for the Italian.
Oh, here we go.
Went straight for the Italian again.
That's fucking right.
Go up.
Go up, Ellum.
Why did you randomly loop?
I don't know.
We got this, gamers.
He gets here all separatist.
We did it, men.
We did it.
Let this be the start of her downfall.
That's not fair.
We just need the event space.
Just because I'm rich doesn't mean I'm different from you guys.
The six stars definitely does.
Here we go.
I'm just like you guys.
When you are DoorDash and your star box is 100 points, this is insane.
The six stars is actually crazy.
Yeah, but I could lose this.
Those are going to be my six stars in the future.
By the chance.
You guys can chance it.
Yeah, I guess.
That's actually true.
That's literally the only way we have this.
We have the custom dice pocket chance.
We have the custom dice chance and try and swap them.
Seven coins.
That's big coinage right there.
It has six stars.
It almost has max coins.
What do you mean almost has max coins?
You were at 175 and you still didn't max it out.
Guys, we need out.
I mean like compared to everyone else, you got so many coins.
If I get a triple dice and then the next turn I buy a custom dice pocket.
I get to the other one, we steal everything from her, she cries.
Just remember, if we do this, we aren't allies anymore.
You have to fully commit.
Oh, this is it.
This is his only chance.
If I need to sell my soul for this win, I'll do it.
This is Macuno's only chance to feel rich.
This is my chance.
I'm gonna steal a small amount of money.
That was your only chance.
That was...
I was hoping to get on the VS space.
That was it.
Guys, just don't push A.
For the poor.
This is the steel kitchen.
I had a hard day.
Most of the coins you have were mine anyway from the revolution.
This motherfucker keeps saying that I'm not in the same position as him.
Dude, we are both broke.
I'm mashing.
Okay, thank you so much.
Okay, so who's been in the worst position?
Elem, who's had two stars and lost it all.
Or is it Macuno who's never had and never lost?
I've never had any stars.
Elem's worse off because he experienced what it was like to be rich, but now he's lost it all.
Exactly.
I think I'm actually all death flooring.
No, you're good.
You got the Koopa back.
Surely there's no way.
I mean, we're all really far away from the next star.
The star is right next to the chance sign.
So you have a chance to get chance sign and the star.
That's true.
You can get the double whammy.
Hope to get to the star.
Oh god.
Oh, you knocked her off.
She's in my way.
You pushed her just like you pushed that woman.
I'm an ally.
Yeah, she wasn't in my way.
She's free to stand there as much as she wants.
How come you guys aren't getting items?
What do you mean?
I got a skeleton key so I can steal everybody's money.
Oh, it's light.
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Oh god.
Perfect.
All part of the plan.
Oh, it's actually a full player one.
Finally.
This is the first one.
Not this one, dude.
What is this?
I don't know this one.
This one sucks.
I hate this one with the passion.
Oh, this one does suck.
Pure RNGesus, dude.
Wait, how do I...
They're eating my friends.
How long do you need to leave it before you get back in the hole?
I don't know.
They're eating the Waluigi.
They're eating the Birdo.
I'm stopping.
Get in.
Dude, I was in.
The delay.
Oh, shit.
We're all dead.
We're done.
Hey, that was a wonderful game, guys.
We're all equal, guys.
I think they should give us 10 coins since it's a tie.
Yeah.
Do you have any coins left?
No, we all lost.
We're all fourth place.
I don't think we care about money at that point.
Like...
We all have so much money.
I don't think it matters anymore.
Speak for yourself, man.
I was supposed to have all the coins.
Those were mine.
Those were my coins.
Don't worry.
See, I am a responsible citizen in Koopa Land.
Here to pay my taxes.
Dude, if I somehow land on Bowser Revolution again, that would be the third.
Surely not.
I mean, at this point, it's going to start to break even.
They're going to give you some money.
You're lucky.
We need a Bowser Revolution for stars.
Oh my god.
That's good.
Yeah, but what do I...
I guess I'll get rid of my skeleton.
Yeah, I guess so.
That makes sense.
Yeah, I don't need it.
Dude, if you stole though, that would be so sickening.
Stealing from the poor?
We don't even have anything she wants.
Yeah, you guys have nothing I really want right now.
So like...
You could steal stars from Chaos.
But if we did, then you...
Yeah, but if you guys start stealing from me, I have to take my chance too.
You need an 18.
An 18 will give you the chance.
I mean, Alan's definitely stealing from you.
You got 18!
You got chance time!
Wait, actually?
You legitimately got chance time.
Wait, which way?
Go to the star.
You want to go left?
I want to go chance time and steal everything from Doki.
Everything.
I thought you were taking everything from me.
Steal from me?
What have I done?
You literally DM'ed me saying you hate British people.
That is a lie!
Show me that DM right now!
You gotta go left, right?
Left?
Go left towards the star.
Okay, okay.
Focus the star.
Focus on the star.
But I need the...
Okay.
You got this.
Towards the star?
Towards the star.
You're literally there.
Alan, just look at the screen.
He's making me panic.
Yeah, he's getting a little panicky.
Even though like...
Oh, this is awesome.
This is where his luck literally turns around.
And just when I actually got rid of my skeleton key too.
Do you know what's gonna happen?
He's gonna buy the one star and give it away.
No!
There's no way, right?
He hits Sykkuno.
He gets that one star and he hits Sykkuno's.
He might have the ping advantage though.
He might.
Here we go.
I just need one star guys, surely.
As long as it doesn't end up in front of Doki, then we're...
Oh, it ends up in front of Alan.
Finally.
Oh yeah.
Are you gonna do the middle one first or are you picking the person first?
It's not even close to me.
Oh, do the people first.
Which is the spicier way of doing it?
You definitely do the people first because if Doki's not involved it's just...
You're right, so try and get Doki in there.
Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
There is some delay when you hit though.
There is some delay.
Why is everybody going against me?
I'm just a little guy.
There's no way you fuck this up.
What did I do wrong?
I'm just trying to hang out.
Alright.
Choose the other person.
Here we go.
Oh!
And surely...
This could be it.
Oh my god!
That's insane, dude.
That's insane.
Holy Jesus.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
He fucking put 25 turns there for a reason.
Wow.
I gave you one star.
At least I'm not last.
You know, at least I'm not last.
I could still get a star.
Hey, now everyone has one star so if you get back in there you could steal three stars.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, I'll just go ahead and do that real quick.
Revenge is sweet.
The British doing it again.
Well, now we have to work together because Elem's gonna win.
Do we all really want Elem to win?
Actually, no, I don't want that at all.
No, wait, but guys, guys.
Guys, do we really want Elem to win?
I did that for the boys everywhere.
What do you mean?
Elem, how can we beat woman?
Do you think we can do an interview?
Not only is this, dude.
But he hates N.A.
He hates the N.A.
people.
I'm an honorary American.
Bakuna always says that.
He always says I'm an honorary American.
Dude, this is the worst luck I've ever seen.
What am I even gonna do with these?
I can't even use them all before the game is over.
That's actually crazy.
That's actually the worst luck I've ever seen an item win.
Hey, you turned around with chance to steal Elem's six stars.
Whoa, Sakuna, you don't need to do that.
Think of what I just did for you.
You didn't even give him the stars.
But my intentions were there.
He has pure intentions.
Which is the main thing.
You know what I mean?
What were your intentions?
You clearly never thought about Sakuna once during the chance game.
I was gonna try and give him the stars there.
But unfortunately, luck be as it is, they all came to me.
How many skeleton keys did they have?
We can all do chance at this point.
Let's all go to chance.
I think that's the only way to go.
You gotta get your money back.
We're all gonna go chance time.
I'm happy with my six, guys.
I'm happy with my six.
Everyone gang up.
Everyone do chance, guys.
What is this?
We have to make a snowball.
Wait, chill.
Oh, what a bad maneuver.
Get him!
Destroy him!
Make sure he has nothing left.
He's in first place now, right?
So we gotta...
We can't let him get money.
Maybe you wouldn't do this to me, right?
I'll break his defense.
Sorry, I pushed it back.
Don't let him get up.
Ellen, why would you do that?
Alright, goodbye.
Go, go, go!
Yeah!
Alright, I'm pretty mad to himself now.
We all get ten coins?
Let's do that.
Throw your ball away as a sign of peace.
Yes, a sign of peace.
Alright, everyone group up.
Group photo, guys, group photo!
I'm standing in the back because I'm tall.
Guys, group photo!
We're just doing group photo, right?
This is what...
Yeah, we're just throwing up some...
Throwing up some snow for the photo, that's all.
Yeah, Chad.
It's gonna look like such a nice photo, guys.
Imagine if you made a snowball right now.
Imagine if you made one snowball right now.
Oh, we have a snowball in the photo!
Let's have a snowball in the photo!
I'm taking a hit!
Get down, Mr. President!
We did it, guys!
We're all winners here.
That was BM and I loved it.
And A, and A, and A!
Oh, we got 20?
Guys, I'm an honorary American.
You guys know this.
If you're an honorary American, why did you...
Why did you steal from the Canadians?
Oh!
Can you make it daytime so I can steal from Ellum?
No, no, no, no.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, I can try.
Yeah, if you could try.
Why did you steal from me?
Well, I can go down to the other one and just take one coin from you.
Or one star.
It feels like that's fair.
You don't give me that.
I mean, I like my stars.
It balances things, you know?
It makes things a little more balanced.
No, no, no, no.
It's okay.
If this is a Kudo's gonna win, I'm gonna laugh my ass off.
Bro, give me a Boo Bell right now.
Dude, it's gonna say he's gonna win.
Oh, where's my reward?
Where did you get it?
One more Skeleton Key.
What are you gonna get?
Our predicted winner!
Oh, a Golden Point!
Golden Pipe's good.
Oh, you can go to a star!
That is awesome.
That's freaking juice, dude.
You should get rid of the Golden Pipe.
What will you get rid of?
Dude, what the?
No way, dude.
No way.
It delayed.
I moved to the right and pushed A and the lag made it go one over.
That's crazy.
That's insane.
The delay actually made it go one over on accident.
That's what I got right there.
Dude, the lag is insane.
No, no, this makes sense because when you do a swap, that way you're not gonna give him a star.
You're not gonna give him a star when you swap now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's right.
You didn't want him to have a star anyway, right?
Yeah, when you swap with him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was the whole plan.
The controls are delayed.
I'm saying, yeah, but you guys are attacking me.
The delay.
Toki, can you roll a one?
It's actually delayed.
I'm gonna grab a triple so I can go to chance.
I'm gonna try.
Okay, but where's the nearest event space?
Is there a way you can get the event space in two balls at the same time?
No.
Insane.
Unfortunately, this is my only chance to.
It actually was delayed.
It was just actually delayed.
I don't think I've ever seen you this unlucky in life ever in any game.
It's delayed.
It's just delayed.
After you sat there for six hours greeting all the fans, this is how you get treated?
That's fucked up, man.
That is so fucked up.
It's lagged.
How do I even play this game anymore?
Gotta get a dongle.
If we all leave the game before turn 25, LM never wins.
Oh, my God.
We have to.
He'll fight the bots and claim it as a W.
Yeah, but he fought.
But then winning against bots is even more sad.
That's true.
You know what?
You're not wrong.
You can't really parade that around as a victory too much.
Yeah, he can't brag about winning if it's against bots.
He might though, but you really can't.
LM, we miss you.
I don't think he's heard us.
Okay.
I'm back.
What did I miss?
We talked so positive about things.
We were making up that.
Did you scheme against me?
I bet you did.
No.
Of course not.
We would never do that to you.
I know what you did.
The delay.
No, the delay.
That's actually insane.
I can't believe that happened.
Okay, I have 14.
I need...
How much do I need?
I thought you were like...
I thought you were like fucking around.
Honestly.
Whose turn is it?
It's mine.
I'm trying to figure out where I want to go.
Oh, you are going to chance time, right?
Oh, you're not going to...
Are you running past chance time?
Did you go too far?
No, I can loop around.
Yeah, I can loop.
I can do a loop-de-loop until I hit it.
Dude, I love that song.
Oh, I can't loop!
No, because the gate's not open!
Oh...
That was a rollercoaster of emotions.
It's alright.
Oh no, you're one behind.
Yeah, I'm one behind.
It's alright, I can loop around.
It's rigged!
I have five turns of this.
I can loop around.
It's true.
I will keep looping until I get it.
Everyone has to throw shit out.
God, my golden pipe.
You know what?
I don't need it.
I want the pipe.
Call chain chomps to make you starve.
I don't think I need that.
What?
I want the pipe!
I feel like it's the weakest thing here.
Alright.
This key is nice.
The key is nice.
The key, I'm gonna use it so I can go to the other one.
Use the key to go to the swap space.
Another chance time in there.
That's your best shot.
I feel like that's your best shot.
We're not talking to you, Elem.
You're not part of this group anymore, Elem.
You're not...
You're not part of this discussion.
This is North America.
Let me back in.
I want back in.
Let you back in.
Give your star to the poor.
I can't even buy the star.
Oh, I can buy it.
You're feeding us for chance time.
That's all.
Just giving us more time to do chance.
Wait.
Stars don't matter at this point.
Nobody's catching up.
Everyone needs to do chance.
You gotta take this going down and then you can hook left.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
You trolled me?
No, you believed me.
Why did you believe him?
Why would he want you to win?
I'm down here too.
I can loop again.
You trolled.
I believed you.
Why?
Dude, this is a GG for me.
A one?
Oh my god.
This is actually insane.
This is...
I'm not even playing the game.
The game just doesn't want me to play it.
Very good.
I don't think I could do this bad if I intentionally tried to lose the game.
There's still four more turns, Sykkuno.
You can turn it around.
I don't even think I could lose this badly if I intentionally was like, I'm gonna throw this game as hard as I possibly can.
And it wouldn't have gone this badly.
Lock it in, brother.
Lock it in.
You can still get a chance time.
We're all relying on chance now.
And actually what you can do too is if you land on someone, it's battle minigame.
So you can fight them for all their money.
Yeah, but we don't want money.
We want the stars.
Yeah, money doesn't matter anymore.
Money is just a cosmetic at this point.
Dude, let me tell you.
I've had a lot of money.
And it's done on me.
And then the revolution.
That twice.
That just once.
I've lost over 150 coins this game.
I'd be at 300 coins if I didn't get it.
Wait, that's good for you though, right?
Because now it turns...
Oh, shit.
Now you can steal.
So I will be attempting to steal from...
Oh, you don't need to do that.
Maybe I'll take from Doki since she's got one.
You should do that.
Nah, money belts.
This one's so bad.
Oh, wait.
This one does...
I hate this one.
This one sucks.
Dude, this one actually sucks.
Why?
Give me the money.
Now I understand why.
Dude, it's so annoying.
Okay, here we go.
Lock it in.
Lock it down.
Remember, money doesn't matter.
Oh, the money matters.
The lag.
There it is.
I don't know if we should let the British guy host.
Yeah, why did we let him host the lobby?
Why did we let the British guy host?
Wait a minute.
I let the British guy host.
You're right.
That's actually a really good point.
People should restart the lobby right now, guys.
I can't even play the game.
Let the British guy host.
Two hours into it, we're like, wait, why is he hosting?
Why did we let him host?
You know what's crazy?
I was saying how I had really bad delay.
I realize I actually don't have any delay because I'm the host.
Yeah, how many of you have delay?
There is absolutely zero lag.
I hope you've been having fun.
Four turns left.
Zero stars.
I've lost over 150 coins.
Don't worry.
It will be different this time.
I got nothing going for me.
It will be different, I swear.
This is it.
This is your time to shine.
Triple eights?
If you get three eights, that would clutch it.
Oh, a 20.
We've got to loop around and steal stars from Elem on the daytime steal, I think.
No, no, no, we don't need to do that.
We don't need to do all that.
Guys, we don't need that.
We just kind of pick and choose.
We just need to do chance.
One more chance.
But guys, think about it.
What if we stole all of Sykkuno's money?
That could be a better option.
I thought money was just a concept.
Yeah, money is just a concept for you.
Right now, man.
Because, well, I'm concerned because Chills is going to steal one star from me and Sykkuno's got 167 coins so that means he can steal three stars from me which means I'm going to be left with like two stars.
You take one from everybody.
Yeah, so you can't lose more than one star.
I'm going to say you're borderline unlosable right now.
Very good, very good.
We'd have to try and lose the game and you wouldn't be able to lose the game.
Very good, very good, very good.
I like how you're just like crushing my numbers, checking my numbers.
I'm just crushing those guys and I'm concerned.
I don't need this.
I mean, surely I get a star by now.
Get this out of here.
So, like, the pool at the bottom, how much does it cost to steal?
23, 50.
I gotta get something.
50?
Downstairs?
Do I have an item?
Oh, I do have an item.
But it's not anything I need.
A six.
A humble six.
Wait, what if I...
I've got an idea.
If it's available, I've got an idea.
I buy a warp block.
And it means that anyone who gets near the chance thing, I'll remove you from there.
And then put myself there.
And we let him win?
And steal more stars for you.
Wow.
As long as you don't hit the happening spot, we're gonna steal one from him.
If each of us steal a star from him, he won't have six anymore.
True.
We all have keys, right?
If I roll low here, then it's GG.
We don't need to do a lot.
I need to roll like an 11.
Five gets you a triple dice block, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why did you go right?
It's so GG.
If you go left, you have a skeleton key to do the swap.
But he can also go the big one.
He can go the big one with...
Oh, this isn't too bad.
You have a key.
And you're gonna go straight up?
This is potential.
Get keys for days.
Oh no.
See, this is so bad for me.
If Elim wants to be super evil, he can swap with Sykkuno.
When does the good luck happen?
What the hell is this?
Oh, yes.
It's time!
When do I feel like I have a chance?
You don't, unfortunately.
If I stole from Doki, that makes me a bad guy, right?
No, if each of us...
I'm gonna steal from Elim too, so we can each distribute the wealth.
So you guys are anti-British.
It's okay.
We can distribute the wealth.
I'm putting the tea in the arbor.
We're getting rid of the tea.
No.
Guys, please.
Not the tea.
Anything but the tea.
You're gonna walk into a sore throat forever.
No.
You'll be fine.
Just walk it off.
But not for me.
You'll be fine.
You have the monarchy.
I don't even know what the monarchy is.
Oh, yeah.
Guys, we can just punch Elim in the face.
That's true.
Get him out.
Where is he?
It's like Feather Party.
Get him out.
Feather Party?
It's like the jumping game from Feather Party.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Screw you.
You are so annoying.
I can't even walk.
Do we just want to try and go for the three wins?
I don't think we can, do we?
Let's all just win here.
No, no, no.
Let's all win here.
No punching, guys.
No punching.
Up one and then we win.
Right side, right side, right side.
Yeah, guys.
Let's go.
What honor among fighters.
Let's go, everybody.
I feel like we're all winners.
I feel like we're all winners there.
What's happening here, guys?
We're all winners.
N-A, N-A, N-A.
Honestly, Elem, I tried to kill him.
It didn't work.
You saw him.
I was punching him everywhere.
You didn't start one punch, you bitch.
No, I punched him off.
I was the one that...
Me and Doki were fighting to the death.
It was Zangief all over me.
We were grappling him nonstop.
We met you with the Stone Cold Steve Austin stunner.
That was amazing.
The Zangief.
You just keep grappling.
You're actually not in a bad position.
Listen, if you take that warp all the way up...
If you can roll like a 10...
If you can roll a 10 this turn...
GG.
No, no, if you can roll a 10 somehow...
That 5 was 5 plus question mark.
Without using your custom block.
I definitely have to do at least one roll without using the custom block.
I'll use the custom block for a 10 after.
What is 5 plus question mark?
We gotta hope for a large number.
5 question mark?
I don't know.
I'd have to be looking at the map.
Oh, you're right.
Can you even custom block to the versus space right now?
I can chance it.
Never mind.
Are you doing it?
Chance it up, man.
Chance it up.
Alright, let's go.
Don't chance it up.
Doki, do you want to know a cheat?
Do you want to know a cheat?
Okay.
So, you can go for the full swap.
That 5 for 1, which you'd have to time.
Which could happen.
Or, if you keep spamming A, the minute you get into the chance time, it will automatically put one star to the left.
As the middle one.
You cringe.
Fuck.
I'm sorry.
Can you explain that again?
Absolutely.
So, you know how it's the middle one spins, and you can kind of pick it, and just hope for the best?
If you spam A as it's loading in, so as you're going through the menus, if you spam A, it will always put an arrow moving to the left.
Or moving to the right.
But it will always put an arrow in contact.
I knew he was the Mario guy.
Okay, so I just go in, and just spam A.
Yes, but that would only be for one star.
It would only be for one star.
I'm gonna risk it.
I'm gonna risk it for the biscuit.
You want the full swap?
Or do I do it for the people, and steal...
Okay, who is this?
Make sure you got the right number.
It's time to roll.
I'm good.
Duel.
Oh.
I'm scared.
Guys, I'm scared.
It's time.
Wait, is that it?
That might actually be it.
Yeah, because I have...
I'm hiding.
Oh my god, that was the craziest roll I've ever seen.
That was insane.
Good luck, man.
Oh boy.
If you take my stuff, we'll never talk again.
If you take my stuff, we'll talk again.
I could actually be last place here.
Yeah, you could definitely put yourself in the last for zero stars.
Okay.
It's like you wouldn't do this.
Oh wait, it's not even Psyche, it's Doki.
Yeah, it's me.
But we all have a chance to do it.
Alright.
Oh yeah.
So it's after yourself.
You don't need a...
Doki, you don't need to do it.
Just get it wrong.
Perfect.
I say choose the other person and then spice for the end.
That's true.
Okay, I'll let luck take this.
Whoever gets it, good luck to all of you guys.
Surely...
No, you're gonna give him money from me.
Please, please give me money.
What if he gets one of his stars?
Please.
I will actually lose my money.
He's a woman-hater.
He's a woman-hater, Doki.
No, I'm a woman-lover.
You're rewarding him.
Doki, I love you so much.
Please reward me.
Doki, don't do it.
I don't know if she even can control this.
Oh, my God.
It doesn't change all that much.
It doesn't change.
Oh, thank God.
We survived.
It was clenching.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
She's got another custom dice.
We can do this again.
I can keep doing this.
We can all keep doing this, guys.
You'll never escape, I tell him.
And then I'm gonna wall-block.
I'm gonna wall-block some people.
Here we go.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
You know that's random, right?
You know that's random.
Oh, no.
I literally went back like two squares.
All in.
Dude, land on him.
Land on him and he can grab stuff.
Yeah.
Do it if you have the guts.
I got some spice in this game.
Oh, my God.
We're going through history.
Joe, do you remember when I said I'm gonna leave you with nothing?
I'm leaving with you with nothing, bitch.
How about one coin?
Just leave me with one coin.
I'm leaving you all in, bro.
Here we go.
All in.
But how am I gonna pay my alimony to Peach?
Dude, I'm like Weevil Underwood when he takes me and rips up a card right now.
I'm going crazy.
I don't think Weevil rips up a card.
I think he throws it in the ocean.
Yeah, you have Kaiba rips up a card and Weevil's just like...
Yeah, Weevil's like, yo, can I see your Exodia?
And he's like, sure.
And then he throws it in the ocean and Joey jumps in because Joey's a real one.
Joey's like, what?
Oh, this is only a 50-foot drop.
I'll be fine.
I'm good with this.
I can do this one.
I can do this.
I'm fine.
Okay.
Dude, Elm's got Host Advantage, though.
This is kinda bad.
Guys, so we're all gonna plug, right?
Here in 24, right, guys?
Oh, I'm plugging.
It's not over yet.
Shields being cringed.
Oh, if anybody falls, it's over.
Oh, it's neck and neck.
Wait, no.
Elm has the Host Advantage.
Right here.
Oh, it is close.
Oh, they both waited.
Oh, they both waited again.
Oh, they're both waiting.
They're so patient.
Dude.
But Elm has literally the Host Advantage.
I know.
I think he's gonna beat me by a drive.
He's gonna beat you by a ping.
I think I landed first.
Dude.
I landed first.
Dude, Elm lost everything.
Elm lost everything.
He lost everything.
I'm gonna take everything.
I've got nothing left.
Oh my god.
Oh, you don't.
I was gonna say your Skeleton Key, you can go and steal another star.
No we take it to the stars.
No.
Wait, Cyclio, you have a chance too.
Yeah, you have a chance.
You can take more than you can really.
I can roll at least above an eight.
Son of a- Oh, you still have two turns.
You still have two turns.
He doesn't want me to play the game.
We just have to make it back nighttime.
I don't understand.
It just doesn't let me play the game.
Lock it in.
Lock it down, brethren.
This luck is insanely terrible.
Don't worry.
The bonus starts.
We'll be there to clutch it.
Yeah, surely.
Does it make more sense to make it daytime now?
Oh, he doesn't even let you.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Why?
Because he's got to go two turns to the other side.
So on turn 25, if nothing changes, it's gonna be GG.
Wait, you can look at all these wonderful things.
Get that custom block.
Oh, and then look at that skeleton key.
Dude, that's impossible.
It's moving so fast.
And the lag is...
Hey, this is not the skeleton key.
I'm gonna say it, bro.
Alright, so we're all blaming LM for hosting in the UK.
Guys, all I can say...
Guys, I want to point out.
Shields are four stars.
Can we just acknowledge that right now?
Five stars.
You stole from me.
You're a thief.
I would never.
Doki, I would never.
You literally stole from me.
Dude, Shield forced my hand.
He forced my hand.
What was I meant to do?
I have that much power?
That's the most insane bad luck I've ever seen.
Okay, I need two tens now, game.
I thought the last time I played this was the worst luck I'd ever have, and here I am.
Hey, I mean...
Wait, that's huge.
16.
That's too much.
He misses it, right?
Yeah, you're too far.
Oh...
I'm really not happy with this.
No.
They should say cooperation, but they don't every time.
Yeah, you're way too far.
You're way too far.
You can buy another triple dice.
You could warp block, and maybe come back.
No, I go custom.
I pray to the gods.
See, I might even take the warp height or the warp eye down, maybe?
Oh, and then do another loop.
Yeah, you can do another loop there.
I gotta just view the board.
Okay, so you're gonna buy the star next round, right?
I'm not even caring about the stars.
I don't know if Sykkuno cares about the stars.
Sykkuno, you're gonna buy the star next round, right?
Am I?
I don't know.
I don't know where it is.
Am I gonna make it there?
He's just been focusing on chance.
He doesn't care anymore.
I'll be honest.
There's almost nothing I can do in this game.
No, you'll be fine.
You're gonna be fine, man.
There's literally borderline nothing I can do to change the outcome of the match.
So you save your custom block, and then you try and get into the chance time area.
Oh.
That's the hope, and that's about it.
Even that, I need to roll higher.
You do need like a 7 or 8 next time.
Here we go.
It's just...
He's lost all hope.
He's actually lost all hope.
You broke this man!
Look what happened!
Dude, the last time I played this, I went 25 turns without a single star.
That is true.
That is unfortunately true.
It has happened again.
Alright guys, I am willing to sacrifice for NA.
No, do not talk to me.
You took my stars.
Do not talk to me.
But then by proximity, Shield has now taken them as well.
So really, who did steal them?
You know?
Ellum.
That's what I'm wondering.
You had your own free will to not do that.
Get it, Doki.
You just punch these blocks, okay?
Get your anger out on the blocks, man.
Quick, Doki.
That's what you get.
That's what you get, Doki.
Oh my god, he's the swimming hitter.
That's what you get.
That's what you get, Doki.
Dude, he's trolling.
That's what you get.
Self-defense.
Dude, you're gonna traumatize Toad.
That's what you get.
Watch this.
What if you beat the shit out of Doki?
This is what you deserve.
Don't call anybody, Toad.
Remember that one Russian dash cam video where like four people in outfits got out and they just started attacking each other?
And you know what?
Let me beat the shit out of Toad while I'm here as well.
Somebody stop him!
He's gonna kill him!
Can I turn around and still beat your ass again?
Wow, what a lovely Sunday drive that was.
Alright, I needed that win.
I don't know what I needed it for.
It's gonna make no difference.
He just wants to feel something.
I have zero stars after 25 turns.
After two and a...
After three hours!
I straight up feel like I could intend to eventually try to throw a game and I wouldn't have done this bad.
But you're gonna get a star right now.
Like none of this adds up to me.
You're like changing right now.
She's gonna triple block and steal your one chance at a fucking star.
No way.
There's no way she takes the one star I have a chance at.
Please.
It's been three hours.
It's been three hours, Doki.
Please, just one star.
Just one star is three hours.
I don't wanna be last.
I'm sorry.
It's been three hours.
Just one star.
It's you or me and I don't wanna be last.
I'm sorry.
I just want one.
Actually, and you have a chance to get to the chance time area.
You roll a high number.
It's you or me.
I'm sorry.
There is no way.
Please.
It's been three hours.
At least you've seen some stars.
You used to have some.
I've never had any.
Yes, so that's even better.
You never had to experience what I had.
I peaked and I don't wanna fall off, Sykkuno.
I don't wanna.
It's too late for you.
It's too late.
Give me a chance.
Oh, Doki.
Dude, in total, guys, he's played about six hours of this game now and still has not had one star.
Still hasn't gotten a star yet.
Hey, look, you get another star.
Oh, I had a chance to get a chance.
Yes.
This is it.
It's literally, you get a one.
He gets a one.
Is that chance time?
Doki, that might be chance time.
No way.
Is it exactly a chance?
There's no way I slowly bleed out and don't win, right?
Sure.
I mean, there's no way that I slowly bleed out.
It is.
Doki, I think you mash the A button.
So you guarantee to take one star in the pot.
Or you random it again.
Up to you.
I say go for the big gamble.
The big gamble will be so much cooler.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Wait, so you're stealing all my money and then you're gonna steal all my stuff.
If I end up with this with 0-0, I'm gonna crush it.
There's no way.
We're gonna go gambling.
Let's go gambling.
Literally.
Oh, that's a lot of money.
I have no coins left.
0 coins.
If I lose all my stars right now, I'm gonna be left with 0.
There's no way.
It'd be great if it was a star swap between Sykkuno and Elem and you earned 0-0.
Wait, what if I...
Okay, I'm gonna grab the star swap and then we'll do gambling on the...
Wait, Doki.
I say do the star swap first.
Hear me out.
If you swap the coins with me and Sykkuno, if he rolls, he can't buy the starry ones.
That would be crazy, but I think the full swapper is the bigger move here.
Yeah, the full swapper.
Hear me out, Doki.
You gotta do the full double swap.
Yeah, we gotta do the double swap.
You don't need to do that.
Oh, this is hard.
I wouldn't worry about it.
We have to target Elem first, though.
We could be helping him.
We could be giving him our money.
And I'm fine with that.
Wait, what was that lag?
What the fuck?
He's lag switching it.
Lag a bit more.
Please.
Oh, shit!
Okay, let's do it!
Let's see if we can get Elem in here.
Dude, this is good.
As long as I'm not giving away coins, anything related to stars is good for me.
No way.
Not me.
Give me somebody else.
Yes!
Give me your stars.
I can't even steal anymore.
I can't even do the triple steal anymore.
I can't even do the triple steal.
He took my coins.
I don't even get to play the game.
I literally don't get...
I've lost over 200 coins!
Okay, what else?
I don't think you buy the stars.
You gotta get 13 coins.
Don't buy the stars!
Don't buy the stars, Sykuno!
You gotta go get...
You gotta get 13 coins.
This is psychotic.
It's been three hours.
Don't get the stars you have.
Get 13 coins, Sykuno.
This is literally it.
You can land on...
You can land on the blue and then you gotta win the minigame.
Those are your options.
Don't get the stars!
Put it all in the triple steal.
It'll be worth it.
You don't need to do it, Syk.
How far can you get in the game?
I can't triple steal because it's gonna be daytime next turn.
I'll do you a favor.
I'll try and aim for the...
Yeah, I have a chance to.
I have a block that changes...
I can change the day for you.
We can aim for that.
The game has just decided I don't get a play.
Three!
Of three!
I think you have so much time.
This is actually insanity how bad my luck is.
You got a star, though!
You got a star!
I'm buying it.
If Bowser takes your star...
Wait, does he land on the Bowser?
There's no way he lands on Bowser, right?
I land on the item, surely.
No, I think you're going to...
You land on Bowser!
Bowser!
Bro, if they take his one star...
He lands on Bowser!
Dude, this is...
Even the one star is a pity star.
It's a pity star.
Oh my god.
Dude, just my luck.
Bowser revolution, I'm gonna give away another hundred coins.
Oh my god.
You gotta be worried about the star.
Yeah, you want a Bowser revolution.
You want a Bowser.
There's a chance you can lose one star.
Oh!
Bowser shuffle!
That's good!
What does that mean?
It just swaps our spots.
Yeah, that's honestly the best case scenario.
At least I didn't lose my star, not that it really matters.
I mean, let's be honest.
There's nothing I can do to come back here.
Dude, Elem's in front of the Stealer.
Yes, yes.
Wait, so where does that put me?
This is crazy.
Where are you?
Where even are you?
Wait, that was great for you.
You might have a 10 for chance time.
You can chance time on your last turn.
Yeah, you can chance time.
And you have a special block.
Dude, with the lag, I won't be able to control it though.
Yeah, that's the best part.
It's gambling.
It's full on gambling.
You can full on test your luck.
With my luck, it's GG.
Clap up.
This is the GG clapus.
It's not...
This is it.
This is what you want.
This is worse than the time I spent over a thousand dollars rolling for a Star Wars character.
See, that's why you don't play TCG games.
Because you can't afford both, man.
That's rough.
Yikes.
Oh, minigame time.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
And we're fighting against Sykuno.
Okay.
What did I miss?
Just beat me up, man.
Oh, you are...
Do it, Doki.
Hit the triangle button again, you sicko.
Hit the dang triangle button, Doki.
How do we do this one again?
We just have to all be on...
Yeah, we just all have to be on...
This game is so rigged.
It's okay.
It's just practice.
Now that you got practice, you have to experience now.
Here we go.
Lock it in.
5-0.
Guys, he's... Sync up.
Sync up.
Oh.
Where is he going?
Wait, he's actually good.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
It's cracked.
He's cracked.
He's right here at the top.
Oh, damn.
Nice dive.
I think he wins.
Oh, we got him.
Oh, what?
Oh, no!
Direction.
It's direction.
He's won.
No way!
He's so lucky!
Oh my god.
Incredible display.
He's not even talking.
He was so locked in.
He was holding his breath, dude.
He's very bright red.
Oh my god.
That was good.
That was impressive.
He was actually so locked in.
He even stopped talking.
Okay, now.
Maybe we don't go for chance time because I'm feeling pretty happy with my position.
No, no, Sykkuno.
It's time.
You gotta do chance.
It's the last...
I'm feeling pretty happy in my...
It's your last chance.
As IT send us.
Final turn, guys.
Final turn.
Oh, Jesus.
Anyone wants a card?
There's like nothing for me to...
There's nothing for me to get.
Like, what does this event space give me?
Dude, I got nothing.
I got nothing.
Oh, it just makes it nighttime?
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright, then I guess I'll just get a lucky space.
If nothing else to get.
Live by the chance, die by the chance, man.
You got this.
Alright, dice time.
I have a dice anyway.
Alright.
Ding, ding.
The most annoying one I could possibly click.
Ten.
I don't think I've even heard that one before.
What the fuck?
Yeah, that one's aggravating.
Alright.
Alright, it's just money time.
Money!
Fifteen coins.
Yay!
The rich be getting richer, guys.
The rich be getting richer.
See, he's the one with five stars.
Boom.
A humble nine.
This guy's got nine.
Time to pay your taxes.
Wait, am I...
One coin.
You know, Sykuno could literally win the game if he gets the chance.
I don't think it's possible.
More money, more money.
You can get the chance, Sykuno.
You have chance.
This is the biggest play of your life.
You can literally make LM be last place in this last turn.
Can he reach it?
Dude, I think it's exactly ten.
Oh my god.
It's ten.
And you have the chance block.
Syk, you don't need to do this, bro.
This is it.
The biggest play of your life.
Dude, I...
It's such a low chance, though.
It's just pure gamba.
That's the best part.
It's the best part.
Syk, you don't need to do this, brother.
I mean, the chance is there.
There is a possibility.
You don't need to do this, brethren.
Think of America number seven.
Think of all the good times you shared.
Prime numbers?
Are we talking about prime numbers again?
You don't need to do this.
This could be it.
I could go down and steal one star, but there's no point.
There's no point.
You don't win.
You're still last place.
Is this it?
I don't want to be involved in this.
Syke... Syke...
Syke, you don't need to do this.
Is it 1 before or 2 before?
Dude, my switch lags a lot so I'm just gonna...
Sykuno...
This is it!
Sykuno... Sykuno...
Sykuno, don't.
Star swap is after...
what?
30?
Wait, what's it after?
I can't even see.
It's after the coin.
Yeah, 30 star swap, then 20, and then it's a full swap.
I don't know what you just said.
Dude, it's going too fast.
I'm lost.
That's Gamba!
I can't even tell either.
Oh, dude, I did it wrong.
Oh, but you get money!
You get money!
You get 30 coins back!
I think I did it once before.
I did it once before, but it's hard.
I think the next one was a star swapper.
This is good, because if you get one bonus star, you won't take less.
Yeah, you won't.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't care about last.
It's either first or nothing.
First or nothing, bro.
What do you mean?
Hey, thanks for the 30 coin loan.
I really appreciate the loan you gave me earlier.
Yeah, dude, if you didn't take that...
Now he could have stolen it.
He could have stolen it now.
If he had one more turn.
One more turn, guys.
He'll give me one.
Just not one.
Zero stars.
Apparently, my chat said you lost 400 coins in total.
Wait, no, Sean.
200 coins?
It was a lot of money.
Jesus Christ.
With all the revolutions?
Yeah, twice in a row.
Revolution.
Alright, we're all in here together, right?
My labor can't handle this.
Wait, I don't even know.
Oh, I'm the fastest.
Yeah.
Well, you're the fastest just because you literally have host advantage.
What in the Turbo controller are you clicking?
I'm cracked out of my brain, I tell you.
It's okay.
He's on his Joy-Con.
There's no way.
Oh, I'm winning this.
Watch this.
Ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Okay, I'm dialing in.
Dialing in.
And...
Whoever's spamming it, you're so cringe.
Holy shit!
How the fuck?
Dude, how?
How?
You're on a Joy-Con!
New record!
Very good, very good, very good.
New record, dude.
Thank you so much.
Where's my Turbo button, bro?
Yeah, right?
Here we go.
Why can't we drift to victory?
It's just so over.
Oh, wait, Sykkuno!
Oh, Sykkuno!
Oh, that's gotta be me.
Dude, there's no way.
I've lost so much money.
What?
What a shame.
I mean, who's gonna win?
I've lost so much money.
What a shame.
Dude, I've lost so much money.
This has gotta be me.
That has to be Sykkuno!
I think it has to be Sykkuno.
Dude, it has to be me for this.
What?
There's no way he's the last one to win!onte even... There's just no way... There's just no way he... It doesn't make any sense.
He was that unlucky, but yet still wins the game!
There's just no way he was less lucky than I was.
And it's not last.
3 hours with no star?
Wait, that's not fair, he has a main character bonus!
So can I win the game today?!
I told you he's the Mario guy.
He's the Mario guy.
No one can tell me all this.
It's called Mario Party for a reason.
Mario won.
Oh my god, that's so good.
I lost like 300-400 points.
I didn't get a star for three hours.
It just doesn't even...
Guys, all the accolades.
This is incredible.
That is the most rigged game I've ever seen.
Someone in my chat was like so unlucky he lost the award for being most unlucky.
Yeah dude, that's how unlucky I was.
I was so unlucky that I didn't even get the unlucky award.
I just don't know how you didn't win the most rich when you made so much money.
I just don't even know how that's possible.
They called you a passionate player though.
I definitely lost.
There's no passion left in these bones though.
This game just hates me.
We can check out the I've done wrong.
We get the scoreboard which is nice.
It gives us like a full breakdown of how it all went wrong.
I don't think I went three hours without getting a single star.
I think that's enough.
There it is.
I think that's enough I needed to see.
Dude, he made so much waste.
Didn't he make the most money?
I made a shitload of coins.
Oh my god.
You made a lot.
Holy shit.
When you gambled against me and I took your 70 coins, that helped.
That counted.
That was why.
I would have won if Elem didn't give you that 120 coins.
I got 13 lucky spaces.
Holy shit.
Damn.
That's the way it goes, guys.
Oh my god.
In the future, we should definitely run it back.
I'm down.
Elem should not be the host for sure.
Dude, I'll play Roblox party next time, alright?
I'll play a Roblox party.
Yeah, I think Roblox party.
It's actually voted.
Good games, guys.
Good games.
GG's.
That was really fun.
It was great hanging out.
It was good playing with you guys again.
Yeah, it was fun.
Bye.
We'll run it back.
Bye-bye.
Oh my god.
That was so fun.
That was so...
I can't believe.
I can't believe how unlucky Sakuro was in the end.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
As long as I wasn't last, I'm happy.
I didn't get robbed in the end.
That's all that matters.
It's fine.
It might not happen first, but I'll just say that he got ping advantage.
That's really it.
Elem had the ping advantage in the end.
Oh my god.
That was fun.
I hope you guys had a great time.
If he didn't land on chat, I could have kept having more stars.
I could have kept going.
It was...
Oh my god.
I can't believe I lost it all because of the fucking chat.
But I hope you guys had a great time watching chat.
It was really fun meeting Chill for the first time with this game.
A huge shout out to Elem for inviting me.
And I had a great time with everybody.
I had a great time with Sakura, Elem, and Chill.
I hope you guys had a great time watching too.
As always, I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flow.
And if you suffer me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.